THANK YOU ALSO FOR JOINING US
TODAY ND I'M SORRY FOR BEING
LATE TO MY OWN.
COMMITTEE HEARING.
MY NAME IS MARC BERMAN AND I
WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
FIFTH AND LAST HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS HEARING IS BEING LIVE
STREAMED IN RECORDED AND WILL
ALSO BE AVAILABLE FOR VIEWING ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE WEB PAGE
WHICH CAN BE FOUND ON MY
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN TAB.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY CALIFORNIA
DEVELOPED A VISIONARY PLAN FOR
THE FUTURE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
KNOWN AS THE MASTER PLAN.
HOWEVER MUCH HAS CHANGED SINCE.
NINETEEN SIXTY POPULATION GROWTH
INCREASE STUDENT DIVERSITY A
CHANGING LEADING INDUSTRIES AND
THEIR NEED FOR TALENT AS WELL AS
THE FIELD OF EDUCATION ITSELF.
REPRESENTING SILICON VALLEY I
SEE HOW QUICKLY TECHNOLOGY IS
ADVANCING ALONG WITH THE RISE OF
NEW INDUSTRIES.
BOTH OF ALTERED STUDENT NEEDS
AND BOOSTED DEMAND FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
WE NEED OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM TO RESPOND TO A HOST OF
ISSUES NEVER PREVIOUSLY
ENVISIONED.
SINCE THE SELECT COMMITTEE WAS
ESTABLISHED IN MARCH OF LAST
YEAR WE HAVE HELD HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO CONDUCT
A THOROUGH LEGISLATIVE REVIEW TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
MASTER PLAN IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR TODAY AND
FOR THE FUTURE.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE STATE'S
PROMISE TO OUR STUDENTS OF
PROVIDING ACCESSIBLE AFFORDABLE
HIGH QUALITY HIGHER EDUCATION TO
EVERYONE WHO WANTS IT WHOEVER
EVERY CHILD WHO WANTS ONE IT IS
QUALIFIED.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE IS THE
FIRST STEP IN A MULTI YEAR
ENDEAVOR TO UPDATE THE MASTER
PLAN.
I'M COMING IN WITH AN OPEN MIND
AND DO NOT HAVE ANY PRECONCEIVED
NOTIONS OR SOLUTIONS AND I
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO DO
THE SAME.
I'LL BE THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE AS BEING
THE INFORMATION GATHERING PHASE
WHERE WE HEAR FROM STAKEHOLDERS
AND COLLECT FEEDBACK.
WHICH IS WHAT WE WILL BE DOING
TODAY.
SELECT COMMITTEE HELD ITS FIRST
HEARING LAST YEAR ON AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST --
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHERE WE
HEARD AN OVERVIEW AND STATUS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS FROM LEADERS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE CSU
SYSTEM THE UC SYSTEM AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS.
THE SECOND HEARING HELD ON
NOVEMBER FIRST OF LAST YEAR AT
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY.
FOCUSED ON CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
AT THIS HEARING WE HEARD FROM
ACADEMICS AS WELL AS THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
WORKFORCE SKILLS GAP THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT WILL
BE FACING OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
THE THIRTY HEARING HELD ON MARCH
FIRST OF THIS YEAR AT FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE FOCUSED ON THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
WE HEARD INCREDIBLY POWERFUL
TESTIMONIES FROM STUDENTS
DISCUSSING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS
FOOD.
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND HOUSING AS WELL AS EQUITY
AND STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE ALSO HEARD FROM THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HIGHER EDUCATION CONSORTIUM AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE YOU SEE
CSU.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
ARE FOR HEARING HELD ON MAY
FOURTH OF THIS YEAR YOU SEE HER
SIDE.
BUILT OFF OF THE DISCUSSION OF
STUDENT NEEDS AND EXAMINE WHAT
FACULTY AND STAFF NEED IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
WE HEARD FROM FACULTY LECTURERS
STUDENT SERVICES STAFF SUPPORT
STAFF AND UNION REPRESENTATIVES.
EARLY NEXT YEAR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE PLANS TO ISSUE A
REPORT SUMMARIZING THE HEARINGS
AS WELL AS RECOMMENDING THE NEXT
STEPS.
SUCH AS WHAT ISSUES NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON IN MORE DEPTH.
TODAY IS ARE FIFTH AND FINAL
HEARING OF THE TO OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
MY GOAL FOR TODAY IS TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF HIGHER EDUCATION
FINANCE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST PANEL OUTLINED THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND HISTORICAL
BACKGROUND OF FUNDING FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AS WELL AS IDENTIFY
KEY CHALLENGES WE FACE IN
FINANCING OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS.
IN THIS PANEL WILL HEAR FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
FROM COLLEGE FUTURES FOUNDATION.
THE SECOND THE SECOND PANEL WILL
DISCUSS THE TOPIC OF FINANCING
STUDENT AID IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS PANEL WILL HEAR AGAIN
FOR A WE WILL AGAIN HEAR FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AS WELL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
AND THE CENTURY FOUNDATION.
THEY'RE ALSO BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING.
AND WE HAVE A SIGN UP --
IS A SIGN UP SHEET FOR FOLKS AT
THE SERGEANTS DESK --
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK DURING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE HAS A
MEMBERSHIP APPOINTED ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS.
AND DE THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING
--
I KNOW WILL BE VERY FORTUNATE TO
BE JOINED BY COLLEAGUES OF MINE
--
HOPEFULLY FROM ACROSS THE AISLE
AND AND FROM THE SENATE STAFF AS
WELL.
PREFERENCE THAT THE SENATE AS
WELL -- MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN INVALUABLE
TO ME AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND WILL PER AND WILL
PROVE INVALUABLE OVER THE COMING
YEARS.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO GET IT
STARTED --
SO THE THE FIRST PANEL WILL BE
OVER THE OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND HIGHER EDUCATION
FINANCE CHALLENGES --
AND WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME UP
PAUL STEED HOUSE IN PRINCIPLE
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
JASON CONSTANT TORE THE ADJACENT
CONSTANT TAURUS CEO FOOT SENIOR
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYSTS AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND MONICA LOZANO PRESIDENT AND
CEO.
OF THE COLLEGE FUTURES
FOUNDATION --
AND WHY DON'T WE GO LEFT TO
RIGHT* MY LEFT TO RIGHT --
STARTING WITH VALUE PAUL.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PAUL
STATE HOUSING WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUR OFFICE IS BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE SOME HISTORICAL CONTEXT
ONE HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING AND
IMPLICATIONS FOR TODAY.
SO I WILL DRESS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUE ADJACENT CONSTANT
TOURISTS WILL DISCUSS THE STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO IN YOUR PACKET IS A HANDOUT
TITLED CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MAJOR BUDGET TRENDS.
AND A HAND OUT FIRST PROVIDES A
SUMMARY OF KEY COMMUNICORP
FUNDING DEVELOPMENTS SINCE
MASTER PLAN ADOPTION.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES MAY HEAD
OUT THEN SHOWS HOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FUNDING SOURCES HAVE
CHANGED THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE DECADES.
THEY HAD ALSO COVERS MAJOR
CHANGES IN THE STATE'S METHOD
FOR ALLOCATING FUNDS TWO THE
COLLEGES AND CONCLUDES BY
IDENTIFYING SEVERAL.
BUDGET AND FUNDING ISSUES FACING
THE LEGISLATURE.
SO YOU CAN SEE FROM PAGE ONE OF
THE HANDOUT.
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF BIG
EVENTS US SUCH AS VOTER
INITIATIVES ECONOMIC UPSWINGS
AND RECESSIONS THAT HAVE PLAYED
A MAJOR ROLE IN SHAPING COLLEGE
FUNDING.
THAT'S A HAND OUT NOTES AT THE
TOP AT ONE TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RELIED PRIMARILY ON
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES FOR THEIR
FUNDING.
THAT WAS WHEN DISTRICTS HAD THE
POWER COMMITTEE BECAUSE
DISTRICTS HAD THE POWER.
SET THEIR OWN PROPERTY TAX RATES
EACH YEAR.
THIS CHANGED ABRUPTLY IN THE
LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION.
THIRTEEN AS YOU KNOW PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN CAP TO THE PROPERTY TAX
RATE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INCLUDING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS COULD CHARGE.
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN ALSO
LIMITED LOCAL GROWTH OF PROPERTY
TAX [inaudible]
A RATES I SIGN THE STATE THE
TASK OF ALLOCATING PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES THANK REALLY CREATED
FOR THE LEGISLATURE A MUCH
GREATER ROLE.
IN TERMS OF FINDING THE COLLEGES
WITH STATE GENERAL FUND MONIES.
AND THROUGH THE YEARS THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC SITUATION HAS
HAD A MAJOR INFLUENCE ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING.
IN GOOD TIMES THE COLLEGES
GENERALLY HAVE SEEN AN UPSWING
IN REVENUES AND SPENDING
ABILITY.
AND THEN DOWN TIMES MOST NOTABLY
THE RECENT THAT GREAT RECESSION
IN THE STATE COLLEGES HAVE
EXPERIENCED REDUCTIONS IN CUTS.
AS THE MIDDLE OF PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT INDICATES AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES
LED TO THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
FIRST COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
ROAMING FI WHICH WAS ABOUT. FIVE
DOLLARS AT THE TIME.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL AS K.
TWELVE EDUCATION HAVE BEEN
GOVERNED BY ANOTHER PROPOSITION
THAT'S PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
AND PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEES A
MINIMUM LEVEL OF ANNUAL FUNDING
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND K..
TWELVE SO IF YOU GO TO PAGE.
TWO YOU'LL SEE AN A GRAPHIC FORM
HOW FUNDING SOURCES HAVE CHANGED
OVER A FIFTY YEAR PERIOD.
AS FROM THE NIGHT MID NINETEEN
SIXTIES THROUGH.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND
FUNDING HERE IS PRESENTED AS A
SYSTEM WIDE AVERAGE PER FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE ADJUSTED
FOR INFLATION SO YOU CAN COMPARE
THE AMOUNTS OVER TIME.
IN THE AREA OF THE GRAPH LABELED
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES YOU
CONCEIVE THE AFFECT OF
PROPOSITION.
THIRTEEN A ON FUNDING YOU CAN
SEE THAT THAT STEEP A CLIP IN
THE LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
AND THAT'S KIND OF DARKER GRAY
AREA YOU CAN ALSO SEE HOW
STUDENTS FEES BEGAN TO PLAY A
ROLE IN COLLEGE FUNDING ALBEIT A
RELATIVELY SMALL ROLE.
AND AS YOU'LL HEAR IN THE SECOND
PANEL THAT'S BECAUSE
HISTORICALLY COMMITTEE COLLEGE
FEES HAVE BEEN THE LOWEST IN THE
COUNTRY ARE AMONG THE LOWEST IN
THE COUNTRIES.
AND THE COUNTRY AND THE STATE
WAIVES THE FEE FOR STUDENTS WHO
DEVON STEVAN STRAIGHT FINANCIAL
NEED.
AND YOU CAN ALSO SEE THERE
TOWARD THE END OF THE GRAPH THE
IMPACT OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION WHICH NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED FUNDING FOR STUDENTS.
AND THEY HAVE QUITE SO
SIGNIFICANT WAY.
AND THEN YOU CAN ALSO SEE THOUGH
AT THE TAIL END OF THE GRAPH YOU
CAN SEE THE THE INCREASE IN
FUNDING PER STUDENT THAT'S
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY.
AND THAT WHEN THIS GRAPH ENDS IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN PER
STUDENT FUNDING IS IT AS IS AT
ITS HIGHEST RATE.
ARE.
THROUGHOUT THESE FIFTY YEARS
SINCE OVER SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENT.
PAGE THREE PAGE THREE PROVIDES A
SUMMARY OF HOW FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE TOP PART OF THE PAGE NOTES
THAT HISTORICALLY MOST FUNDING
HAS BEEN PROVIDED TWO COLLEGES
AS GENERAL PURPOSE MONIES WHICH
THE COLLEGES CALL APPORTIONMENT.
OVER THE YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DESIGNATED MORE AND MORE
FUNDING FOR SPECIFIED PURPOSES.
FROM STUDENT SERVICES TO CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION TO
FACILITIES MAINTENANCE.
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES
BEFORE PROPOSITION.
THIRTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES ONLY
HAD ONE CATEGORICAL PROGRAM THAT
WAS A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAM AIMED AT
LOW INCOME --
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS.
BY TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE HE CREATED
NEARLY.
THIRTY A CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT 25% OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR COR BUDGET.
NOW LARGELY AS A RESULT OF TAX
BASE DIFFERENCES THAT PREDATE
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
HISTORICALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE RECEIVE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS OF FUNDING.
A PER STUDENT TO SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS.
IN THE MID TWO THOUSANDS THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED FUNDING
OVER A SEVERAL YEAR PERIOD TO
EQUALIZE PER STUDENT FUNDING
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND JUST TO NOTE THAT THIS
EFFORT AFFECTED APPORTIONMENT
FUNDING FOR CREDIT IN STRUCK XIN
WHICH IS LARGELY COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSES.
DISTRICTS ALREADY HAD BEEN
RECEIVING THE SAME PER STUDENT
AMOUNT FOR NONCREDIT INSTRUCTION
WITCHES ARE LARGELY PRE
COLLEGIATE ADULT LEVEL TYPE
CLASSES.
HISTORICALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE RECEIVED A PORTION FUNDS
BASED ON ENROLLMENT.
FUNDING THAT WAY HAS CREATED A
STRONG INCENTIVE FOR COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO STUDENTS.
BUT THERE'S BEEN CRITICISM OVER
THE YEARS THAT FUNDING BASED ON
ENROLLMENT DOESN'T CREATE A
STRONG INCENTIVE FOR COLLEGES TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
SUCCESSFULLY MAKE IT THROUGH A
PROGRAM AND EARNED A DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE.
SO JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR AGREED
TO FUND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPORTIONMENT SPACE AT LEAST IN
PART ON STUDENT OUTCOMES SUCH AS
DEGREE AND CERTIFICATE
ACHIEVEMENT.
AND AS THE HEAD OUT DOES NOTE
NONCREDIT APPORTIONMENT
CONTINUES TO BE BASED ENTIRELY
ON ENROLLMENT.
NOW THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA ALSO
GIVES A SUPPLEMENTAL PER STUDENT
AMOUNTS FOR COLLEGES ARE SERVING
LOW INCOME STUDENTS TO EACH LOW
INCOME STUDENTS COLLEGE SERVES
GETS AT A BUMP IN IN THE AMOUNT
OF PROPORTIONATE FUNDING IT
RECEIVES A GRAD.
AGAIN FOR CREDIT INSTRUCTION.
AND THIS IS TO RECOGNIZE A
GENERALLY HIGHER COSTS THAT
COLLEGE IS IN HER TO EDUCATE THE
STUDENTS.
ALONG WITH THE NEW FUNDING
FORMULA THE LEGISLATURE
CONSOLIDATED THREE STUDENT
SUPPORT PROGRAMS INTO A BLOCK
GRANT.
THAT'S AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE.
THREE SO PAGE FOR A REALLY TAKES
A LOOK AT YOU IN LIGHT OF THIS
HISTORICAL CONTEXT IN LIGHT OF
RECENT BUDGET RELATED CHANGES.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES FACING THE LEGISLATURE?
THE FIRST IS THE HAND OUT A AS
NOTED OVER THE YEARS COMMITTEE
COLLEGE FUNDING HAS BEEN
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY
RECESSIONS AND STRONGLY AFFECTED
BY RECESSIONS.
THE MAIN PROTECTION AGAINST CUTS
DURING RECESSIONS IS A STRONG
RESERVE AND BY THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT THE STATE WILL
HAVE.
A TOTAL RESERVE OF ABOUT SIXTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
AS YOU'LL HEAR A WAY AGAIN WHEN
YOU DISCUSS THE UNIVERSITIES AND
IMPORTANT ONGOING ISSUE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
IS WHAT LEVEL OF RESERVES TO
SHOOT FOR IN THE COMING YEARS.
SECOND THE LEGISLATURE FACES AN
ONGOING QUESTION OF HOW MUCH
FUNDING IS PROVIDED VIA
APPORTIONMENT AS OPPOSED TO
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS.
NOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE OFFICIALS
TENDER [inaudible]
PREFER APPORTIONMENT GIVE THEM
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS
LOCAL PRIORITIES OF THE
ADVANTAGE OF RESTRICTION AS
RESTRICTED FUNDING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
TARGET FUNDS [inaudible]
FOR STATEWIDE PRIORITIES.
THIRD THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT
TO MONITOR CLOSELY THE EFFECTS
OF THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA ON
COLLEGE OPERATIONS AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES TO RESOLVE
IS WHETHER NONCREDIT INSTRUCTION
SHOULD BE FUNDED AS A BASE AT
LEAST BASED IN PART ON STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
NOW RELATED TO THE ISSUES OF
BOTH SPENDING FLEXIBILITY AND
THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
OF THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
DECIDE WHETHER OTHER CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS SHOULD BE CONSOLIDATED
SOME OF THE OTHER TWENTY SEVEN
OR SO THAT ARE STILL INTACT.
THE LAST POINT ON PAGE FOUR OF
THE HAND OUT CONCERNS FUNDED
INSTRUCTION AND WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD PROMOTE MORE
NONTRADITIONAL INSTRUCTIONAL
STRATEGIES STRATEGIES THROUGH
ITS FUNDING POLICIES. FOR
EXAMPLE BEST PRACTICES IN OTHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS IDENTIFY
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION AND
PRIOR LEARNING ASSESSMENT SUCH
AS CHALLENGE TESTS ON COURSES.
AS A WAY TO ACCELERATE STUDENT
PROGRESS YET CURRENTLY COLLEGES
DO NOT HAVE A STRONG FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE TO LET ALREADY SKILLED
STUDENTS BYPASS CERTAIN CLASSES
IN PURSUIT OF A DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE.
ALSO LOOKING AHEAD THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO REVISIT
HOW FUNDING POLICIES CAN BETTER
SUPPORT NONTRADITIONAL
INSTRUCTION AND THIS GOES TO
YOUR POINT AT THE BEGINNING IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS THAT MISTER
CHAIR ABOUT.
AYE WAIT LOOKING FOR WAYS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATECAN
RESPOND TO INNOVATIVE CHANGES
THAT.
THAT HAVE NEVER PREVIOUSLY BEEN
ENVISIONED SO THERE THERE MIGHT
BE INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES IN
THE FUTURE WE HAVEN'T EVEN
DISSIPATED NOW AND JUST KEEPING.
THE POLICIES AND THE LEGISLATIVE
AYE ON SOME OF THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS AS THEY OCCUR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JASON CONCENTRA SALLY รณ.
MY PRESENTATION WILL FOCUS ON
THE TWO UNIVERSITY SEGMENTS AND
I WOULD DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO
THAT HAND OUT ON THAT THAT'S YES
YOU AND YOU SEE MAJOR BUDGET
TRENDS.
THE FORMAT OF MY PRESENTATION
WILL BE VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU
HEARD IN THE CCC PRESENTATION.
OF FOCUS FIRST ON A MAJOR
FUNDING DEVELOPMENTS OVER THE
YEARS ALL THEN FOCUS ON HOW
CHANGES IN THE WAYS THE STATE
HAS DETERMINED HOW MUCH FUNDING
TO PROVIDE THE TO UNIVERSITY
SEGMENTS.
AND THEN I'LL CONCLUDE WITH SOME
AREAS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER AS YOU
REVIEW BUDGET PRACTICES FOR THE
TO UNIVERSITY SEGMENTS. ONE
THING NOTE TO KNOW JUST BEFORE I
DELVE INTO THE HAND OUT OF MY
PRESENTATION WILL FOCUS
PRIMARILY ON WHAT WE REFER TO AS
CORE FUNDING.
THAT IS STATE FUNDING AND
STUDENT TUITION AND FEES THESE
TWO SOURCES OF FUNDS ARE WHAT
ARE THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF FUNDS
FOR THE EDUCATION BUDGETS.
CRAWFORD CS YOU AND YOU SEE.
OTHER MORE SELF SUPPORTING
ENTITIES SUCH AS FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR RESEARCH GRANTS MEDICAL
CENTERS STUDENT HOUSING AND THE
DINING AND RECREATION AND OTHER
ACTIVITIES LIKE THAT WILL BE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS PRESENTATION.
RETURNING TO PAGE ONE WE PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE KEYED
A DEVELOPMENTS OVER THE YEARS OF
INVOLVING CORE FUNDING.
I THINK YOU CAN CHARACTERIZE ALL
OF THESE DEVELOPMENTS OVER THE
YEARS AND IT INTO KEY TRENDS THE
FIRST IS.
OVERALL CORE FUNDING FOR A CSU
AND YOU SEE.
OVERALL CORE FUNDING HAS BEEN
SOMEWHAT VOLATILE OVER THE YEARS
--
INCREASING WHEN OF STATE
REVENUES WERE GENERALLY STRONG
AND DECREASING WHEN STATE
REVENUES WERE GENERALLY WEAK.
AMONG OTHER VOLATILITY HAS
ESPECIALLY BEEN ON THE EDGE THE
STATE GENERAL FUND SIDE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT A FUNDING PER
STUDENT OVER TIME OF TUITION AND
FEES HAVE TENDED TO BE A
SOMEWHAT MORE --
A STABLE REVENUE SOURCE FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES.
AND SECONDLY IN TERMS A MIX OF
CORE FUNDING --
BETWEEN STATE GENERAL FUND AND
STUDENT TUITION AND FEES.
BUT YOU'LL NOTICE THAT OVER TIME
STUDENT TUITION AND FEES HAVE
BECOME INCREASING SHARE OF CORE
FUNDING.
NOW THAT SAID.
A WE WOULD NOTE THAT AS OF
TUITION AND FEES HAVE INCREASED
SO HAS FINANCIAL AID SPENDING
AND YOU'LL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT FINANCIAL
AID IN YOUR NEXT PANEL.
A BUT AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
INCREASE IN TUITION FEES OVER
TIME I KEEP IN MIND THAT SOME OF
THAT IS A GENUINE COST INCREASE
FOR CERTAIN CALIFORNIANS AND
HOUSEHOLDS.
BUT OTHER OTHER PORTIONS OF THAT
HAVE BEEN COVERED BY THE STATE
OR BEEN REDIRECTED BACK TO
STUDENTS IN THE FORM OF
FINANCIAL AID.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO I WE
PROVIDE A A GRAPH THAT YOU SAW
SIMILAR TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PREFER CSCO.
AT SHOW STATE OF FUNDING AND A
STUDENT TUITION AND FEES OVER
TIME.
AND HERE AGAIN YOU CAN SEE A LOT
OF THE TRENDS ARE HIGHLIGHTED
YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S BEEN
SOMEWHAT VOLATILE OVER THE
YEARS.
I WAS CERTAIN PEAK SUCH AS IN
THE LATE EIGHTIES AND ALSO IN
THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS FOLLOWED
BY A DECLINES IN PER STUDENT
FUNDING.
GENERALLY CORRESPONDING TWO
YEARS WERE THEIR RECESSIONS ARE
THERE WERE BUDGET REDUCTIONS AND
YOU CAN SEE A LOT OF THAT
VOLATILITY IS BENT ON THE STATE
FUNDING SIDE.
LIKEWISE YOU CAN ALSO SEE THAT
TUITION AND FEES OVER TIME HAVE
BEEN AN INCREASING SHARE OF CORE
FUNDING.
AND ALSO TO CIRCLE BACK TO THAT
POINT AND MADE ON FINANCIAL AID
SPENDING AND TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT OF THAT A
STUDENT TUITION AND FEES LINE IS
ACTUALLY BEING REDIRECTED FOR
FINANCIAL AID EITHER.
BEING COVERED BY THE STATE'S CAL
GRANT PROGRAM WORKING BRAG
REDIRECTED BACK TO STUDENTS SO
THAT JUST GIVES YOU A SENSE OF
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS BEING BORNE
BY -- BY
STUDENTS VERSES AB HADN'T BEEN
FOR FINANCIALLY PROGRAM.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE OF
THAT HAND OUT YOU'LL SEE A
SIMILAR TABLE FOR YOU SEE AGAIN
THE TRENDS ARE VERY SIMILAR
YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF A NOTABLE
VOLATILITY IN THE OVERALL LEVEL
OF CORE FUNDING.
AND YOU ALSO SEE AGAIN --
THE INCREASING SHARE OF STUDENT
TUITION AND FEES AND AND
COVERING COR FUNDS.
AGAIN JUST A CIRCLE BACK TO THAT
POINT ON FINANCIAL AID ABOUT
SEVENTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
STUDENT --
AND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IS IN THE IN
THE STUDENTS TO IT AND FEES
CATEGORY IS ACTUALLY BEING USED
FOR FINANCIAL AID EITHER THROUGH
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM ARE BEING
REDIRECTED BACK TO STUDENTS FOR
FINANCIAL AID.
TURNING TO PAGE FOUR OF THE
HANDOUT WE PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF SOME OF THE CHANGES IN THE
WAYS THE STATE HAS BUDGETED.
I THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES OUR OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE BUDGET
PROCESS WAS A LOT MORE FORMULA
DRIVEN --
THE EVER EVER EVER NEW STUDENT
THAT THE UNIVERSITIES AND ROLL
THEY'VE GOT A CERTAIN SUBSIDY
FOR THAT NEW STUDENTS --
THERE WERE ADDITIONAL --
FUNDS FOR VARIOUS COST INCREASES
SUCH AS COMPENSATION INCREASES
--
ANYTIME THERE IS A NEW PROGRAM
ADDED THERE IS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THAT.
AND EVERY AND FOR CERTAIN
FACILITY PROJECTS EVERY TIME
THERE IS A NEW FACILITY THAT WAS
PROPOSED AND ADOPTED IN THE
BUDGET THERE WAS FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THAT NEW FACILITY
PROJECT.
BEGIN IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES A
LOT OF THIS FORMULA DRIVEN
APPROACH --
STARTED TO DECLINE AND AND
GIVEAWAYS TO A MORE FLEXIBLE
BUDGET PROCESS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S.
OF AN EVOLVING A MORE NEGOTIATED
PROCESS BETWEEN THE LEVEL OF
SUPPORT --
AND ALSO IT AND IN DOING SO THE
LEGISLATURE A DEFAULT A LOT OF
THAT A CONTROL IT HAD OVER THE
BUDGETS REALLY GAVE MORE CONTROL
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
SEGMENTS TO MANAGE THEIR COST
INCREASES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH OF THE OLD ENROLLMENT
FORMULAS WERE VERY DETAILED AND
PROVIDE A DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
SUBSIDIES DEPENDING ON IF THE
STUDENT WAS AN UNDERGRADUATE OR
GRADUATE.
AND ARE STANDING IS IN SOME
CASES EVEN IF THE STUDENT WAS
ENROLLED IN A CERTAIN DISCIPLINE
LIKE AT SCIENCE OR HUMANITY.
ON IN THE MID NINETIES THE
LEGISLATURE REVISE THAT A
FORMULA AND CREATED A MUCH
SIMPLER FORMULA FOR BOTH SYSTEMS
THAT PROVIDED ONE SUBSIDY FOR
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
UNDERGRADUATES AND GRADUATES.
THEY GIVE THE SECOND MORE
CONTROL TO MANAGE ROMANS ACROSS
THE SYSTEMS.
AND IN CERTAIN YEARS THE STATE
HAS NOT SET ROMAN TARGETS IN THE
BUDGET OR DESIGNATED FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH I MET ALSO GIVES PUTS
MORE RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
SEGMENTS TO REALLY.
SET THAT AS A PRIORITY OF
THEMSELVES.
LIKEWISE FOR OTHER EXPERT OF
COST INCREASES ARE NOT RELATED
TO ENROLLMENT SUCH AS
COMPENSATION COSTS IN RECENT
YEARS A LOT OF THE OF THE
SEGMENTS HAVE BEEN EXPECTED TO
COVER THOSE COSTS THROUGH.
A GENERAL PURPOSE BASED
INCREASES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
THEM GENERALLY IS BASED
INCREASES ARE DETERMINED ON A
SOMEWHAT NEGOTIATED BASIS A
PARTICULARLY AT IN RECENT YEARS
IT'S BEEN VERY MUCH THAT
DIRECTED BY.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION IMPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION THING THAT.
PROVIDING ANY ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATIONS THAT IT SEES FIT
THOSE YEARS --
LIKEWISE FOR VARIOUS PROGRAMS ON
A LOT OF THE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS THAT EXISTED IN THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS --
THROUGHOUT THE SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES ALSO THAT WERE ADDED
IN TWO THOUSANDS A LOT OF THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE FOLDED INTO THE
UNIVERSITIES GENERAL PURPOSE
SUPPORT AND OF A SEVERAL YEARS
AGO.
THOSE PLOT OF THIS PROGRAM STILL
EXIST BUT THE FUNDING IS NOW IN
THE CONTROL OF THE SEGMENTS OF
THE SEGMENTS REALLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALLOCATING FUNDS TO THOSE
PROGRAMS IN REVIEWING THEIR
CONTINUE NEED.
AND THEN FOR FACILITIES OF THE
STATE AS A FEW YEARS AGO A
REVISED THE WAY IT IT --
REVIEWS FACILITIES AND IT GIVES
A LOT MORE GIVE A LOT MORE
CONTROL OF THE SEGMENTS. TO
APPROVE NEW FACILITY PROJECTS AS
PART OF THAT PROCESS ALSO GAVE
THE SEGMENTS MORE
RESPONSIBILITY.
FUND THOSE NEW PROJECTS.
NOW IN ADDITION TO THAT TREND --
I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT I'M
YOU'VE HEARD SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT PERFORMANCE BASED
BUDGETING IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SOMEWHAT DISCUSSION IS
ALSO EXISTED IN OF ON THE
UNIVERSITY SIDE.
OTHER STATE FEW YEARS AGO
DEVELOPED PERFORMANCE MEASURES
THAT THE UNIVERSITIES MUST
REPORT ON EACH YEAR THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
LIKE GRADUATION RATES LOWER O.
INCOME STUDENT ENROLLMENT THE
UNITS THAT STUDENTS ACCUMULATE
WHEN THEY GRADUATE OTHER VARIOUS
MEASURES OF THAT SORT.
CURRENTLY THE SEGMENTS REPORT ON
THOSE PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND
ITS INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES --
UNLIKE THE NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FORMULA THOSE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AREN'T REALLY
INTEGRATED ANY SORT OF BUDGET
FORMULA OR ANY OTHER SORT OF WAY
WE BUDGET FOR THEM THEY'RE
THEY'RE SORT OF INFORMATIONAL AT
THIS POINT.
SO SKIPPING ACTUALLY HERB PITCH
FIVE MOVING TO PAGE SIX FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME.
I'M ONE OF THE TOUCH ON SOME KEY
AREAS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER AS A
REVIEWING BUDGET PRACTICES FOR
THE UNIVERSITIES --
MY COLLEAGUE PAUL ALREADY
DISCUSSED.
THAT FIRST POINT ABOUT SETTING
AN OVERALL RESERVE JUST AS THAT
MIGHT CONTROL SOME VOLATILITY
FOR THE COLLEGES ALSO CONTROLS
IT IT COULD HELP YOU SOME OF THE
VOLATILITY FOR THE UNIVERSITY
SEGMENTS.
AND SECONDLY AS YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT BUDGETING YOU MAY WISH TO
THINK ABOUT WAYS THAT OF THE
STATE HAS BUDGETED FOR THE
UNIVERSITY SEGMENTS IN THE PRO
AND THE APPROACH THAT YOU THINK
MAKES MOST SENSE TO YOU.
WHETHER OR NOT THE OLD FORMULA
DRIVEN APPROACH MADE SENSE OF
WHETHER THE CURRENTLY THEM MORE
NEGOTIATED --
SYSTEM MAKES SENSE AND IN DOING
SO YOU MAY WISH TO REVIEW WHAT
LEVEL OF CONTROL YOU'D LIKE TO
EXERT OVER THE UNIVERSITY'S.
OUR STATE OTHER AS YOUR BUDGET
ADVISER.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A KEY ROLE IN SHAPING THE
PRIORITIES IN THE BUDGET
PRIORITIES OF THE SEGMENTS.
I'M SO THE UESTION FOR YOU IS
REALLY HOW MUCH CONTROL YOU LIKE
OVER THESE VERY VERY VERY
SERIOUS HOW MUCH CONTROL YOU
LIKE OVER SETTING ENROLLMENT
TARGETS.
REVIEWING COMPENSATION LEVELS.
AND POSSIBLY REVIEWS IT RIP
REVIEWING OTHER POLICIES TO FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE VERY
RECENTLY HAS USED THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO REVIEW THINGS LIKE
NON RESIDENT ROLE MEANT.
PENSION BENEFITS FOR YOU SEE
EMPLOYEES AND VERY RECENTLY
ADOPTED -- A
CATEGORICAL LINE ITEM FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT'S OTHERS
ARE SOME WAYS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS --
TRY TO RE EXERT SOME CONTROL
OVER THE BUDGET PROCESS --
OFFER REGARDING PERFORMANCE A
BASED BUDGETING YOU MAY WISH TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WHICH IT SEGMENTS
REPORT INFORMATION.
IS REASONABLE OR WHETHER OR NOT
OF THE LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO DO
MORE.
TO INTEGRATE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES INTO THE BUDGET
PROCESS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE LEGISLATURE
FACES THE PERENNIAL ISSUE OF HOW
TO SHARE COSTS BETWEEN THE STATE
AND STUDENTS WHAT SO BUT LOOK
PORTION OF THIS OF COURSE FUND
SHOULD BE SUPPORTED BY THE STATE
WHAT PORTION SHOULD BE SUPPORTED
BY STUDENTS.
RECOGNIZING THAT FINANCIAL AID
DOES COVER THE COSTS FOR
STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY FOR
FINANCIAL AID.
AND SO FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO
AREN'T.
FINANCIALLY NEEDY UNDER THOSE
PROGRAMS.
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE SHOULD THE OF
COST OF THOSE STUDENTS A PAY IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR EDUCATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISSILES ANA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BERMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
MONEY COME THOSE SIGN UP
PRESIDENT OF THE COLLEGE FUTURES
FOUNDATION.
THE COLLEGE FUTURES FOUNDATION
STANDS FOR EQUITY OF OPPORTUNITY
AN OUTCOME FOR CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE STUDENTS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS K. TWELVE STUDENTS
ARE OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME YET
THE STUDENTS FACE NUMEROUS
BARRIERS TO ATTAINING BACHELOR'S
DEGREES.
AND FORM A MINORITY OF GRADUATES
FROM OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
A HIGH QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
COLLEGE EDUCATION MEANS
OPPORTUNITY.
AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES YET
NUMEROUS SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
STATES YET TOO MANY.
QUALIFIED STUDENTS CANNOT ACCESS
SEIZE OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE OF
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS IN HOW WE
FINANCE HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE COLLEGE FUTURES FOUNDATION
BEGAN EXAMINING COLLEGE FINANCE
BECAUSE OF GROWING CONCERNS AT
THE SYSTEM OF PAIN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS BECOME A BARRIER
TO INCREASING BACHELOR DEGREE
ATTAINMENT.
AMONG ALL STUDENTS AND HAS
BECOME PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING
FOR LOW INCOME AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS.
THIS LET US TO WORK ON THE TOPIC
OF HIGHER ED FINANCE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE ELEMENTS AND THE
ISSUES AND WAYS TO EXPLORE
SOLVING IT.
OUR PRIMARY FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
THE CSU AND THE UC WHICH
EDUCATES NEARLY THREE QUARTERS
OF THE STATE'S BACCALAUREATE
RECIPIENTS.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS WE HAVE
CONVENED A SERIES OF
CONVERSATIONS AMONG INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEEP EXPERTISE ON PUBLIC
POLICY AND HIGHER ED FINANCE.
AND COMMISSION SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF RESEARCH MY COMMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ARE A
REFLECTION OF THIS ANALYSIS AND
THE EXPLORATION OF THE ISSUES.
A GROWING CONCERN.
THE HIGHER IT FINANCE PROBLEM
HAS WORSENED OVER THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS BECAUSE OF GROWING
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE BETWEEN
REVENUES AND SPENDING.
AS WE HEARD HIM FLUSH ECONOMIC
TIMES THE STATE CAMPAIGN MORE
TUITIONS HOLD STEADY AND COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT IS EASIER IN BAD
TIMES THE STATUS FORCED TO MAKE
DRASTIC BUDGET CUTS INSTITUTIONS
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO CAN BE ADMITTED.
AND TUITION SKYROCKET.
WHEN GOOD TIMES RETURN SPENDING
INCREASES AGAIN INTUITIONS ARE
HELD STEADY BUT NOTHING
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES SO WHEN
THE NEXT RECESSION ROLLS AROUND?
THE CYCLE THE BUDGET CUTS
TUITION INCREASES AND ENROLLMENT
COMEBACK CUT BACKS REPEAT.
NO ONE IS WELL SERVED BY THIS
WILD RIDE OF HIGHS AND LOWS NOT
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES NOT THE
STATE NOT THE INSTITUTIONS OR
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THEM AND
MOST PARTICULARLY.
NOT STUDENTS WE MUST FIND A
BETTER WAY TO MANAGE HIGHER
EDUCATION FINANCE ENROLLMENT
LEVELS.
AND TUITION BY TAKING ON
PREDICTABILITY OF REVENUES
ADOPTED BUDGET BY OFFERING
PRACTICE SAYS AND RIGOROUS
CROSSED MANAGED COST MANAGEMENT.
BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS.
WE SEE FOR ASPECTS TO THE
FINANCE CHALLENGES FACING
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES.
VOLATILE REVENUE PATTERNS
INCLUDING STRETCHES OF DECLINING
STATE GENERAL FUND REVENUES
LINKED WITH GROWING DEPENDENCE
ON TUITION.
BUDGETING PRACTICES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE FIXED COSTS OF EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS.
ACADEMIC OR INSTRUCTIONAL COST
STRUCTURES.
AND STATE AND INSTITUTIONAL
DECISION MAKING THAT FUNCTIONS
WITHOUT SHARED MEASURES COMMON
GOALS AND MUTUAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
GIVEN THE SOLUTIONS THAT REQUIRE
ATTENTION TO ALL FOUR OF THESE
BARRIERS BUT THOSE TIME LIMITS
THAT I HAVE I'M GOING TO FOCUS
ON THREE OF THEM.
REVENUE INSTABILITY COST
MANAGEMENT AND TRANSPARENCY IN
DECISION MAKING FINALLY ARE
CLOSE WITH THE SHORT ANALYSIS
AND A DESCRIPTION OF THE
PROBLEMS.
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES FACE IN
TERMS OF CAPITAL FINANCE WHICH
WE MUST ADDRESS IF WE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE GROWING DEMAND
FOR POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
[inaudible]
REVENUE VOLATILITY.
AND A GROWING DEPENDENCE ON
TUITION THIS IS THE MOST WIDELY
DOCUMENTED AND BEST UNDERSTOOD
FAST OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
FINANCE PROBLEM.
THE UNPREDICTABLE STATE REVENUE
LEVELS LINK TO INCREASES IN
TUITION BY UNIVERSITIES.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE SOURCES OF
REVENUE IN CALIFORNIA'S GENERAL
FUND HAVE SHIFTED SUBSTANTIALLY
AND OF RECENT DECADES.
A PERSONAL INCOME TAX AND HIGH
INCOME TAXPAYER THE INCOME
EARNED BY THESE TAXPAYERS IS
MORE DEPENDENT ON CAPITAL GAINS
MAKING THE GENERAL FUND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED IN
ECONOMIC BOOMS AND BUSTS.
THIS WAS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WHEN STATE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY SHRANK 4% BUT
GENERAL FUND REVENUES DECLINED
BY MORE THAN 19%.
AS GENERAL FUNDS DROP TUITION
STARTS TO STUDENTS INCREASED AND
TUITION IS NOW THE LARGEST
REVENUE SOURCE FOR CORE PROGRAMS
IN THE UC AND HALF OF COR
REVENUES AT THE CSU.
AND GIVEN THAT MAJOR TAX REFORM
IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY WE MUST FIND
WAYS TO BUFFER AGAINST THESE
INEVITABLE PRECIPITOUS DECLINES.
BUDGET AND PRACTICES ASSOCIATED
WITH FIXED COSTS.
BOTH STATE UNIVERSITY BUDGET
PRACTICES TREAT EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS AS FIXED COSTS WHICH
MEANS AIR FUNDED AHEAD OF OTHER
PRIORITIES.
EVEN AS REVENUE HAS BECOME LESS
PREDICTABLE A LARGER SHARE IS
NEEDED TO PAY FOR THE FIX
BECAUSE OF EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
PENSIONS AND RETIREE HEALTH
CARE.
BENEFIT LEVELS HAVE IMPROVED.
BUT THE PRIMARY COST DRIVER HAS
BEEN THE COST OF HEALTHCARE AND
CHANGES IN ACCOUNTING RULES THAT
NOW REQUIRE BENEFITS COMMITTED
TO BE RETIREES TO BE SHOWN AS
INSTITUTIONAL LIVE BILL IT IS
OUR DEBTS.
PENSION GUARANTEES PENSION
BENEFITS ARE GUARANTEES AND
CANNOT BE REDUCED FOR EXISTING
EMPLOYEES OUR RETIREES NOR WOULD
WE RECOMMEND THAT.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
PROBLEM A SPENDING ON BENEFITS
IS WELL RECOGNIZED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY AND
WHATEVER CHANGES THAT THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN MUST HAPPEN SLOWLY
OVER THE YEARS.
STATE AND INSTITUTIONAL DECISION
MAKING STAYED IN INSTITUTIONAL
DECISION MAKERS TOO OFTEN ARE
WORKING ACROSS PURPOSES WITHOUT
COMMENT CALLS SHARED LANGUAGE OF
MUTUAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
STATE GOVERNMENT IN HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE COMPLEX SYSTEMS
THAT RELY ON MULTIPLE DECISION
MAKERS AT VARIOUS LEVELS OF
AUTHORITY.
THE ABSENCE OF SHARED GOALS
COMMON FISCAL BENCHMARKS IN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS HAMPER
ATTEMPTS TO ADEQUATELY PLAN FOR
AND MANAGE RESOURCES IN A WAY TO
ADVANCE [inaudible]
STUDENT SUCCESS.
THE WAY FORWARD.
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
CHALLENGE WE THINK A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH.
THAT INCLUDES REVENUE BY
OFFERING TUITION STABILIZATION
AND PREDICTABILITY COST
MANAGEMENT AND PRODUCTIVITY
IMPROVEMENTS ARE REQUIRED. TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THESE.
REVENUE AND TUITION
PREDICTABILITY THE STATE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM SHOULD ADDRESS.
REVENUES MOVING TO REDUCE
VOLATILITY FROM YEAR TO YEAR AND
BUILD BETTER PREDICTABILITY FOR
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS.
THIS SHOULD OCCUR THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF MODERATE AND
PREDICTABLE INCREASES IN GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT FROM THE STATE.
MODERATE AND PREDICTABLE
INCREASES IN TUITION BY COHORT
ACCOMPANIED BY NEED BASED AID TO
PROTECT COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
AND INCREASES IN THE CONTINGENCY
RESERVES DEDICATED TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THE LONG STANDING HABIT OF
BUYING OUT TUITION IN GOOD TIMES
AND LETTING THE LEVEL SPIKE IN
RECESSIONS NATURE AND STUDENTS
THE INSTITUTIONS AND OUR STATE.
ARE BETTER SERVED THROUGH MODEST
AND PREDICTABLE ANNUAL INCREASES
IN TUITION.
MATCHED WITH SAME SIZE GROWTH IN
STATE FUNDING.
AND THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
FOR EMPLOYEE BENEFITS SHOULD BE
AT REVISED TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND TO ILLUMINATE
TRADE OFFS BETWEEN SPENDING ON
BENEFITS AND OTHER OPTIONS.
INCLUDING SALARIES NEW FACULTY
POSITIONS LOWER INCREASES IN
STUDENT TUITIONS EXCEPT TRACK.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT A
COMPREHENSIVE PROBLEM REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION AND
ILLUMINATING BOTH THE COST AND
THE REVENUE SIDE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE DECISION MAKING
REQUIRED IN SHARED GOVERNANCE.
IS THE PATH FORWARD.
NOW LET ME TURN VERY QUICKLY TO
CAPITAL FINANCE.
I'VE JUST DISCUSSED WITH HIM.
THE IMPORTANT ELEMENTS.
OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM REVENUE
VOLATILITY EMPLOYEE SALARIES
BENEFITS EXCEPT FOR BUT THERE IS
ANOTHER MASSIVE EXPENSE LOOMING
ON THE HORIZON.
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH EXPANDING
FACILITIES AT OUR PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
WE NEED A SYSTEMATIC APPROACH TO
PAY FOR RENOVATIONS REPAIRS AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BEGINNING
WITH DECISIONS ABOUT REVENUE
SOURCES AND WAYS TO ESTABLISH
FUNDING PRIORITIES.
THIS REQUIREMENT IS MADE EVEN
MORE APPARENT BY THE FACT THAT
OUR COLLEGES ARE UNABLE TO MEET
THE DEMAND OF GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE
SLOTS.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE GRADUATION
RATES HAVE NOW SHOWN SUCH
DRAMATIC IMPROVEMENT.
THE PROPORTION OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES HAVE COMPLETED THE
COURSES REQUIRED ADMISSION TO UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY.
AND WE SHOULD PROVIDE A PLACE
OUT OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FOR THESE QUALIFIED
STUDENTS.
IT WILL BE CHALLENGING BUT IT IS
BOTHNECESSARY AND DO A BALL AND
THAT THERE'S NO TIME TO WASTE.
SO THE NEEDS IN CAPITAL
FINANCING IN HIGHER ED --
ENORMOUS AND GROWING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE UC IN THE CSU HAVE ESTIMATED
THAT THEY WILL NEED A COMBINED
FORTY SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION.
TO CONSTRUCT NEW FACILITIES ARE
MODERNIZE EXISTING FACILITIES IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS ALONE.
THE GROWTH IN UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT.
NEEDS TO BE ACCOMMODATED WE NEED
TO FUND ALLOCATIONS FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY IN A WAY THAT IS
CONSISTENT AND CLEAR.
AND THE HISTORIC SEPARATION
BETWEEN OPERATING AND CAPITAL
BUDGETS ONLY CONTRIBUTES TO THE
FUNDING PROBLEM.
AND OF COURSE AS WE ARE NOW
DEFERRED MAY NEEDS ARE GROWING
AN ON GOING BASIS AND
MAINTENANCE HAS BEEN CUT
SIGNIFICANTLY.
SO WHAT OTHER CHALLENGES THERE
ARE WAYS TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
IN CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO MOVE AWAY
FROM THE CURRENT APPROACH. TO
HIGHER EDUCATION CAPITAL
FINANCE.
TOWARDS AB MUCH MORE WELL
DEFINED SYSTEMIC APPROACH.
COLLEGE FUTURES FOUNDATION IS
TODAY INVOLVED IN A RESEARCH
PROJECT TO DIDN'T DETERMINE THE
CAPACITY CHALLENGE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
TO TWENTY THIRTY THIS INCLUDES
ASSESSING CONTRIBUTORS TO DEMAND
AND SUPPLY ALONG WITH WAYS FOR
BETTER UTILIZATION OF FACILITIES
ACROSS HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
INCLUDING COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE MUST BE
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO MAXIMIZE
SPACE AND COORDINATE BETWEEN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
SO IN CONCLUSION.
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE HANGS ON
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE A QUALITY
EDUCATION TO EVERY STUDENT WHO
IS QUALIFIED AND MOTIVATED TO
SEEK A COLLEGE DEGREE.
SOLUTIONS MUST INCLUDE A FOCUS
ON AFFORDABILITY AND TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE WHICH I KNOW OUR
NEXT PANELIST PREPARED TO
ADDRESS.
BUT ACHIEVING SOLUTIONS POSED BY
THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION REQUIRES A SYSTEMATIC
AND THOUGHTFUL APPROACH.
THAT TAKES THE LONG VIEW.
AND IT'S HEARTENING TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
TAKING THE ISSUE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION FINANCE SERIOUSLY AND
EXPLORING THOUGHTFUL SOLUTIONS
TO REAFFIRM OUR STATE AND THE
MASTER PLANS COMMITMENT TO
ACCESS OF OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MISS
LOZANO LOZANO --
AND I LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US --
TODAY AND GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY DE MAKE ANY
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS THEY WANT
OR ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
BUT WE HAVE US IN THE MEMBER
MEDINA CLOSE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WE HAVE DOCTOR WEBER
--
WHO'S A MEMBER OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE IN HAS BEEN I THINK
EVERY HEARING --
WE HAVE --
SOME MEMBER MCCARTY WHO'S NOT A
MEMBER CHAIR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL --
OVERSEEING BUDGET EFFORT FOR
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIA --
AND DOCTOR EGGMAN --
WHO'S ALSO BEEN I THINK
PRACTICALLY EVERY HERE AND WE'VE
HAD -- SO
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND WHEN I OPEN
IT UP TO YOU FOR ANY.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
WORSE I GROUP TODAY --
GO.
FOR WELL FIRST OF ALL THAT I'M
NOT A MEMBER OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE BUT I THINK YOU --
FOR NOT INVITING YOU BUT SHARING
IT AND YOU KNOW ASKING AT ASKING
THE SPEAKER TO US TO FOCUS ON
THIS ISSUE --
THAT THE MASTER PLAN.
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IS A
DOCUMENT SIXTY YEARS ALL THOSE
NEVER QUITE CODIFIED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT IT KIND
OF ARE BLUEPRINT.
I THINK IT BEGS THE QUESTION --
Y. WITH THE CREDIT SIX YEARS AGO
DOESN'T MEET THE THAT THEY GOALS
OF TODAY --
BACK THEN IT WASN'T PEOPLE THE
FIGHTING EVEN AT HIGHER
EDUCATION AS MUCH AS WE DO.
NOT KNOW TODAY AND WE KNOW IT'S
THE TICKET TO KNOWLEDGE AND THE
WHOLE CLASS JOB BUT HARD.
ECONOMIC AB.
WELDING OF THE FUTURE AND THE
LAST FIVE YEARS THAT THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE'VE INCREASED HIGHER
ED SPENDING IN UC AND CSU MANY
COLLEGES BY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION.
WHEN YOU HAD ARE INCREASING CAL
GRANT IT'S TWO TWO BILLION BUT?
THE WORLD'S ARE TREMENDOUS
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY.
IS IS STILL A HUGE ISSUE WE'RE
HEARING IT HERE AND HERE FOR THE
NEXT PANEL --
AS WELL.
AND I THINK THIS.
IS REALLY THAT THE STATE'S FROM
WHERE WE WANT TO GO WE DO HAVE A
NEW ADMINISTRATION COMING IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS --
SO I THINK --
IT ALLOWS US TO TALK ABOUT --
OUR PRIORITIES FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION I KNOW A LOT OF THESE
YOU KNOW THAT SWIRLS AND WHAT DO
WE DO ABOUT IT AND WHERE IS THE
MAGIC.
POT OF MONEY IN ISRAEL HIDDEN
SUITCASE UNDER HERE WITH A
COUPLE BILLION FOR HIGHER AT
DURING THE BUDGET SUFFER FOR
YEARS I HAVEN'T SEEN IT BUT
STILL I'M STILL LOOKING FOR IT.
BUT BUT YOU DO RAISE SOME ISSUES
AT THE AYE I'M SUPPORTIVE OF IS
THAT I THINK THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE.
A STABLE SOURCE OF STATE MONEY
EVERY YEAR TO THE UC AND CSU
KNOWS DEBATE THIS PAST YEAR
WHETHER IT'S THREE PERCENTER FOR
AND YOU KNOW.
THE HARD THING IS WE GET 3% AND
IT JUST PAYS FOR THE BASICS
SPACE FOR HEALTHCARE COSTS YOU
BASICALLY DON'T GET ANY.
NEW SLOTS FOR STUDENTS WHO DON'T
GET ANY INCREASED AFFORDABILITY
INOTES CAO LIKE GETTING A BUDGET
TO REMODEL YOUR HOUSE AND ALL
YOU HAVE IS MONEY FOR YOUR NEW
PLUMBING AND ELECTRICAL YOU
DON'T GET ANY NEW.
THINGS THAT YOU'D LIKE FOR YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AND SO THAT'S KIND OF
THAT THAT TACKLE THAT WERE THAT
GOOD THE ISSUES ARE TRIED TACKLE
IS THAT.
SO MUCH OF THE COSTS ARE JUST
FOR THE BASICS YOU DON'T EVEN.
THE FAMILIES AND ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY AND SO FORTH SO IT
SO YOU DID MENTION THE STATE
GOING FORWARD.
AND HAVING A COMMITMENTS WHETHER
IT'S THE STATE'S 5% PER YEAR.
GOD INCREASE MONEY WHICH I KNOW
THE SYSTEMS WOULD BE VERY
PLEASED WITH HE SAID THE
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE.
TO PAY IN SOME OUT TO I'M NOT
ADVERSE TO THAT I KNOW THAT SOME
PEOPLE SOME FOLKS ARE ARE BARELY
ADVERSE TO STUDENT FEE HIKES I I
GET IT BUT THERE'S NO.
FREE LUNCH HERE ON BUT I WILL
NOTE THAT WITH ALL THE STUDENT
FEE INCREASE IS GRANTED THAT'S
YOU KNOW.
SUPER WEALTHY CAN AFFORD IT --
YOU KNOW THE MIDDLE CLASS THE
ONES THAT ARE GETTING SQUEEZED
IT'S A LOW INCOME ONES THAT GET
CAL GRANT AND FINANCIAL AID SO
THAT'S COVER ANYWAY.
THAT JUST COMES FROM THE STATE
AS WELL SO YOU KNOW ALMOST A
THIRD TO HALF OF THE MONEY.
THAT YOU THAT FOR THAT STUDENT
FEE HIKES YET TO COME BACK AND
GET CALIFORNIA TO PAY AND IN
INTO IT AGAIN.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER IS TO THAT AND AND IF
THAT IS IF SO THAT MAKES MAYBE
THE STATE CONTRIBUTION.
MAYBE 6% DRIVEN HIGHER SO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT'S ALL
SUSTAINABLE AND SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
LOOK AT COST CONTAINMENT AND YOU
SEEN CSU WHAT CAN BE WHAT CAN WE
DO DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE THIS IS
NOT AN AND ENOUGH TO GO AROUND
BUT I WILL ASK YOU ON THAT.
ON THEM MODERATE AND PREDICTABLE
FEE INCREASES IS THERE A
CERTAIN.
DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT YOU THINK THE
THE COLLEGE FEATURES FOUNDATION
IS LOOKING THERE IS NO DOLLAR
AMOUNT WHAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING
IS AN APPROACH.
AND WERE ACTUALLY --
ABOUT TO UNDERTAKE AND ANOTHER
SET OF RESEARCH QUESTIONS.
THAT WOULD LOOK AT IT
COMPREHENSIVELY SO IF YOU PAT IF
YOU MODEL THIS OUT OVER.
YEARS WITH THE WORD MULLIN OUT.
TO TWENTY THIRTY WHAT WOULD THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF COR REVENUE
GROWTH BE ON ANY SINGULAR YEAR
MATCHED WE WOULD HOPE IN TUITION
SO THAT IT'S MODERATE
PREDICTABLE.
TUITION WOULD HOLD WE WOULD
ASSUME FOR A COHORT SO WHEN
YOU'RE INCOMING FRESHMEN.
YOU BASICALLY KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE PAYING BY THE TIME
YOU GRADUATE SO THAT THERE ISN'T
THAT KIND OF UNPREDICTABILITY.
SO THAT THE PRINCIPLES WOULD BE
STABILITY OR REVENUE DOES
PREDICTABILITY REDUCED
VOLATILITY.
AND THEN TO YOUR POINT SENATOR
WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT THE COST
MANAGEMENT HAS TO BE A PART OF
THIS SO PUTTING IN PLACE SOME
PRODUCTIVITY MEASURES THAT IF
THOSE WERE APPROVED --
THEN IN FACT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
RELEASE OF RESERVES HOW WOULD
YOU CREATE SOME SORT OF A
STABILIZATION FUND SO THESE ARE
ALL CONCEPTS THAT WERE.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT. ONE
THING BY ITSELF CAN'T SOLVE THIS
RIDDLE IT REALLY HAS TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE AND SO WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING SOME WORK THAT LOOKS AT
BOTH.
IDENTIFYING WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL FOR RESERVE
GIVEN THAT THERE IS AN
INEVITABLE DOWNTURN WHAT COULD
TUITION LOOK LIKE WHAT SHOULD
THE COR REVENUE.
STREAM BE IN TERMS OF GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT.
AND THEN WHAT KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AROUND
COST CONTAINMENT AND
PRODUCTIVITY SO ALL OF THAT
TOGETHER.
PERHAPS COULD BEGIN TO LOOK
LIKE.
IS THAT --
COULD BE SUPPORTED BY THE PUBLIC
THE SYSTEMS THEMSELVES AND AND
HOPEFULLY THE LEGISLATURE OF IF
THAT BE THE CASE.
THEN MAYBE HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE LA JOH YA THE GOVERNOR AND
EVEN SHE FELT LIKE.
LET'S HAVE ANALYSTS SAID THAT
YEAH RECESSION MAYBE.
COMING ONE DAY AND WE CAN'T
COUNT ON THIS.
THESE INCREASE WE'VE SEEN FOR
THE PAST FIVE YEARS AND SO --
HOW DO YOU VIEW THE LONG TERM
FUNDING STRUCTURE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND?
AND HOW WE SHOULD YOU KNOW
ADDRESS THIS.
THIS COMPLEX --
FINANCE ORBITAL.
WELL I THINK WE'D ECHO A LOT OF
THE THINGS THAT --
CALLED FUTURE JUST NOTED ON I
THINK ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES
IF YOU IF YOU LOOK HISTORICALLY
HAS BEEN THAT VOLATILITY.
AND SO I THINK ONE OF THE KEY
TOOLS YOU HAVE AT YOUR DISPOSAL
IS.
TO SET UP SORT OF RESERVE IN THE
BUDGET EVERY YEAR THAT YOU CAN
DRAW ON WHEN TIMES ARE ARE BAD
THAT'S THAT'S A KEY TOOL BEFORE
YOU AND THINKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SETTING THAT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENT YOU ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER RESERVE THAT YOU HAVE
MORE CONTROL OVER YOU HAVE A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT HERBS THAT
YOU CAN DRAW ON WHEN WHEN TIMES
ARE.
BAD AND THAT SORT OF THE THE KEY
TO I THINK WE WOULD COURAGE YOU
TO THINK ABOUT AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT WAYS.
TO HAVE A FUNDING BE MORE
PREDICTABLE MUST VOLATILE
[inaudible]
A MS MEDINA.
BUT IT THANK GOD I DON'T FOR
COMING AND HER PRESENTATION --
AND AND I THINK THE SUBJECT THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING IS PROBABLY TO
ME.
AS CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT.
AND IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND AND I HAVE FELT.
THAT IN MY SIX YEARS HERE.
SERVING ON THE COMMITTEE OF
HIGHER ED.
AND AND AS THE CHAIR.
THAT THERE HAS BEEN.
NO MORE IMPORTANT --
POLICY QUESTION THAN JUST THAT
THE FUNDING.
AND IT IS I AND I HAVE SAID.
AND I THINK I'VE SAID IT ALMOST
EVERY YEAR THAT IT IS.
UP SOMEHOW. TO ME --
JUST [inaudible]
SHOCKING REALLY THE THAT THE
METHOD THAT WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
EVERY YEAR TO THAT FUND HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND AND I SAY SHOCKING BECAUSE
YOU KNOW AS THE EXPERIENCE IS
SHOWN --
EVERY EVERY YEAR WE KINDA.
STOP BONUS START FROM SCRATCH.
IT FEELS THAT WAY --
AND FINDING THE FUNDS TO TO FOR
THE TO FIND HIGHER EDUCATION AND
SOME YEARS I WE DO BETTER THAN
OTHERS.
CERTAINLY IN THIS PAST YEAR
WE'VE DONE WELL.
BUT IN PREVIOUS YEARS WE HAVEN'T
DONE SO WELL AND IT SEEMS AND I
AM.
I THINK IN PERFECT AGREEMENT
THAT THERE HAS TO BE A BETTER
WAY.
AND THAT THAT IS A INCUMBENT
UPON THIS AS THE LEGISLATURE TO
FIND THAT BETTER WAY.
OF THAT WE WE WE SHOULDN'T HAVE.
TO DO WHAT WE GO THROUGH EVERY
YEAR -- THAN
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
I I UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES
AND I THINK.
I DONE A GOOD JOB OF OF TELLING
US WHAT THOSE CHALLENGES ARE --
BUT I YOU KNOW WOULD I COMMIT TO
WORKING.
WITH THIS CHAIR AND CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE OF SUB TO TO
FIND A BETTER WAY.
AND AND I THINK THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA THE STUDENTS TO
CALIFORNIA --
ARE DESERVING OF THE BETTER WAY
AND CERTAINLY FOR WHETHER YOU'RE
A PARENT.
BUT WHETHER YOU'RE STUDENT AND
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH OF
WONDERING YOU KNOW HOW MUCH IS
TUITION GOING TO GO UP.
EVERY YEAR WHILE YOU'RE A
COLLEGE STUDENT IS SOMETHING
THAT STUDENTS AND PARENTS
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
SO I I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS I KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT.
THAT SUBJECT BUT CERTAINLY ONE
THAT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
THING YOU'RE MUCH DOCTOR WEBER
YES UP BUT I THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR FOR THE INFORMATION AND I
THINK THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN A
LITTLE WHILE.
I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW IT'S COMPLEX ISSUE IN
TERMS OF FUNDING AND FINANCING.
WHAT DO YOU --
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU IN A PERFECT
WORLD.
BUT WHAT WE DO.
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW IS REARRANGING
THE CHAIRS ON THE TITANIC.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
THING'S GOING DOWN A MEDICAL SO
--
SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IN A
PERFECT WORLD.
OF WHAT WOULD WE DO AND NO OTHER
PLACES HAVE TALKED ABOUT OF THE
STATES HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
OF PAYING IT FORWARD IN TERMS OF
FREE SPEECH EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN PAY FOR IT
AFTER THEY GRADUATED AND SO THAT
CREATES A DIFFERENT STREAM OF
RESOURCES.
BRING WHAT WOULD WE DO I YOU
KNOW I'M FROM THE WEALTH FROM
THE ORIGINAL UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CALLED THE ORIGINAL
THAT LESS OF A LONG TIME WE PAID
NO TUITION.
WILL ONLY PAID FEES EIGHTY
DOLLARS A SEMESTER AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHEN I START
TEACHING PAID.
THIRTY SEVEN FIFTY A SEMESTER
THEY PAID FEES IT NEVER PAID FOR
THE PROFESSORS IN THE EDUCATION
SO WHAT DOES NOT AS YOU CAN SEE
LOOKING AT THE CHART AND HOW
IT'S CHANGED SO DRAMATICALLY.
SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
IN A REAL WORLD HOW DO WE GET
BACK TO THAT --
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WHEN WE
TALK UP HERE WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW.
AND NOT THINGS THAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
AND WE OTHER SO SEEM TO BE.
SOME OF THE STATES ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT
DIFFERENTLY AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
--
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO KNOW
I AM SURE LIKE MOST FOLKS USE
HER TO MY TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
HOW WE DO TAXES IN CALIFORNIA IS
ALL WRONG.
AND DATA AND SO AS A RESULT IN
THE OLD WAY WE HIT SEEM TO BE
MUCH MORE STABLE AS FUNDING.
BUT THAT'S A DIFFICULT ISSUE TO
BITE OFF WITH THE PUBLIC.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME IF THEY
HAD SOME ASSURANCE THAT THERE
WOULD BE SOME DRAMATIC CHANGES.
LIKE FREE EDUCATION LIKE WE USED
TO HAVE.
IT MIGHT BE POSSIBLE TO THROW
THAT INTO THE CONVERSATION SO.
AS AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA NIGHT OF
THE DAY BUT TOMORROW.
IT'S WHERE WE ALMOST BECOME --
BILL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DEPRESSION PROVEN SOMEWHERE
RECESSION PROOF IN SOME WAY OF
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY WE FUND
THINGS AND HOW WE OPERATE.
KNOW WHAT DO YOU FOLKS CMU YOU
THE NUMBERS CRUNCHERS IN THE
FINANCIERS AND ALL THOSE FOLKS.
IN A REAL WORLD AND AND I SHOULD
SAY IT WILL WORK IS WHEN THAT
NOW BUT IN AN IDEAL WORLD WHAT
WOULD WE DO.
I KNOW WE CAN SAY WE COULD
STABILIZE FUNNY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS --
IN A WORLD IT'S UNSTABLE OKAY SO
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE WHAT WE
TALKING ABOUT AND AND AND HOW DO
WE GET THERE.
WILL YOU IDENTIFY OF A FEW
PROBLEMS --
VOLATILITY OF REVENUES
PRIORITIES DO YOU HAVE YOU KNOW
FREE COLLEGE FOR ALL OR DO YOU
EXPECT SOME INDIVIDUALS TO PAY
FOR THEIR COST OF EDUCATION.
THOMAS OTHERS ARE THAT ARE GOING
TO HAVE DIFFERENT IN A POLICY
[inaudible]
OCCASIONS THERE --
I I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TO POINT
OUT THAT.
YOU NO YOU DON'T LIVE IN AN
IDEAL WORLD WHERE YOU HAVE.
ALL THE RESOURCES THAT YOU
NECESSARILY WANT TO WORK WITH
AND YOU CANNOT PERFECTLY PREDICT
WHATTHE BUDGET IS GOING TO BE.
FIVE YEARS OUT AND IN SOME CASES
IN OUR OFFICE.
IN WE WE DO FORECAST EVERY YEAR
OFTHE BUDGET --
AND EVEN PREDICTING WHEN YOU'RE
OUT THERE IS UNCERTAINTY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
SO YOU DO HAVE TO YOU TO FACE
THAT REALITY IN A WE RECOMMEND
STARTING A RESERVE EVERY YEAR IN
THE BUDGET.
ABOUT THE EXACT LEVEL OF RESERVE
YOU SHOULD SET YOU KNOW IS OPEN
TO DEBATE AND IT'S GONNA INVOLVE
YOUR PRIORITIES IN THAT YEAR.
BOB YOU ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S DONE THIS
IN THE PAST IT DID YOU KNOW KEEP
ONGOING PRIORITIES DOWN AND AND
WE COMMIT SOME FUNDING TO ONE
TIME PRIORITIES WHEN TIMES ARE
REALLY GOD KNOWS HER. TWO WAYS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE THAT.
ON BUT AGAIN YOU THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE SOME UNCERTAINTY
WITH THEBUDGET THERE YOU REYES
ARE A KIND OF PRE NO QUESTION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE WHICH IS.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU BUDGET FOR
SOMETHING ABOUT HOW DO YOU HAVE
A LONG TERM VISION WHEN IT'S
HARD TO PROJECT PREDICT THE
FUTURE?
AND SOMETHING THAT WE STRUGGLE
WITH IN THE YOU KNOW THE OFFICE
AS WE TRY TO ADVISE YOU ON THESE
ISSUES BUT I THINK AGAIN YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S SETTING ASIDE
FUNDING EVERY YEAR IN THE
BUDGET.
THINKING ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW
WHEN TIMES ARE REALLY GOOD
THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THE ONE
TIME YOU KNOW PRIORITIES AND
LIABILITIES IN THE STATE AND
PAYING THOSE DOWN.
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE SOME
PRACTICES THAT YOU HAVE AT YOUR
DISPOSAL.
AND THEN THINKING ABOUT YOUR
PRIORITIES IN WHICH WOULD LIKE
TO FUND IF YOU OF YOU KNOW WHAT
SHOULD THE SHARE OF COSTS BE
SHOULD IT BE FREE EDUCATION FOR
ALL SHOULD SOME STUDENTS BE
EXPECTED THEIR SHARE THE COST OF
THEIR EDUCATION.
THAT'S GONNA FALL MORE ON WHAT
YOUR PRIORITIES THINK THE
STATE'S ROLE ISM AND FUNDING
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT YOU KNOW
COULD DIFFER DEPENDING ON WHAT
YOUR PRIORITIES ARE.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS I
FIND -- A I
GUESS IT'S LIKE.
SOME KIND OF A MAGIC FINANCING
THE WHATEVER IT IS.
FOR US THAT WE ARE THAT WE HAVE
MONEY.
THAT WE PUT INTO FINANCIAL A
OKAY AND THEN TURN AROUND AND DO
SOME OTHER THINGS TOO SO THAT IN
THE END.
THOSE OF PAYING.
FOR PAYING SOME FEES I PAYING IN
FOR THE FINANCIAL AID I ASSUME
OF OTHERS AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT IT'S ALL THIS MONEY THIS
FLOAT AROUND HERE IT EVEN IN OUR
FINANCIAL AID.
AREA OF THAT IF WE DIDN'T DO
THAT AT ALL.
AND PUT IT ALL BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM.
RATHER THAN GIVING OUT SOME
FINANCE A TO A FEW.
A BUT THE P. WOULD PROBABLY SEE
IT MORE AS A FREE EDUCATION.
NO ONE OF THE THINGS IT SEEMS
WHEN I'M TALKING TO PEOPLE AND
I'M SAYING WELL.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS ALMOST
FREE WE DON'T YOU KNOW BECAUSE
EVERYBODY THE GET A BOB GRANT OR
SALT WATER SOME THAT PAYS FOR
EVERYTHING OR YOU GO TO THE I
KNOW WE HAVE THE DREAM GROUP NOW
IT'S HE SEES YOU.
AND WE HAVE SOME OF THE STUFF
THAT AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
IT BECOMES VERY CONFUSING WITH
THIS CHART WHERE.
YOU KNOW STUDENTS ARE PAYING
THIS BUT IN REALITY WE PAID IT.
AND SO AND IT ALL GETS TWISTED
AROUND AND I'M SO SO.
HOW MUCH DO PEOPLE REALLY PAY TO
GO TO SCHOOL?
OKAY AND DO THAT IF YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH DID DID IT REALLY COST THE
STUDENTS.
ALL OF US GIVING BACK TO THEM
WHAT WE CHARGE THEM.
ILL A SO I'M JUST GONNA.
HE'LL FIGURE OUT A SIMPLE WAY TO
DO THIS.
AS AS WELL AS MIGHT INSPIRE US
TO DO MORE.
OF BECAUSE WE HEAR ABOUT THE
TREMENDOUS TUITION STUDENTS ARE
PAYING AND IT'S THERE BUT THEN
WE HEAR ABOUT THE INCREASE IN
FINANCIAL A AND ANYTIME WE
INCREASE FEES WILL INCREASE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
[inaudible]
SO.
WHO IS REALLY PAN TO GO TO
SCHOOL?
I MEAN THAT I THINK THAT'S A
QUESTION AND WE STRIP OPET WEEK
IF WE GAVE NO FINANCIAL AID AT
ALL.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN IN TERMS
THAT POT OF MONEY THAT'S IN
FINANCIAL AID?
THAT NOW GOES INTO THE SYSTEM
ITSELF TO FUND STUDENTS.
WHAT WILL WHAT WOULD IT LOOK
LIKE?
IF ANYBODY ASK THEMSELVES THAT
HAVE YOU GUYS AS A QUESTION
WOULD INTO ANY FINANCIAL AID PUT
ALL THE MONEY THAT WE GIVE
FINANCE WAY BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN HAVE TO CHARGE
STUDENTS TO GO TO SCHOOL?
YOU KNOW I HAD I DON'T HAVE AN
ESTIMATE ON THAT ON IN YOUR
FINANCIALLY PANEL --
WE DO HAVE A HANDOUT WERE
REDESCRIBED --
WHEN YOU FACTOR IN [inaudible]
OF THE VERY IT NOT ONLY OF THE
STATE SUBSIDY BUT ALSO STATE
FUNDING FOR FINANCIAL AID AND
KNOCKING OUT.
THE TUITION DISCOUNTS THAT
STUDENTS GET RIGHT HOW MUCH IT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY PAYING UNITS IT'S LESS
THAN I THINK PEOPLE REALIZE
SOMETIMES IT'S ON OF THE NUMBERS
AND FROM ME BUT IT'S LIKE 5% OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THAT'S MAYBE ROUND 17230% AT UC
AND CSU AT THE ACTUAL.
NUMBERS ARE IN YOUR HAND OUT SO
I WOULD DEFER TO THE BUT ON I
SAY WE HAVE DONE THAT EXERCISE
IN TERMS OF IF WE WOULDA.
IF WE WERE TO PUT FINANCIAL AID
ALL OF THEM FUNDING BACK IS A
DIRECT SUBSIDY FOR THOSE IT OF
SEGMENTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WOULD STUDENT
CHARGES BE ADJUSTED TO AYE AYE
THAT I DON'T HAVE THAT IN FRONT
OF ME BUT THAT YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S A CALCULATION MAYBE YOU
COULD DO IF.
YOU KNOW THINKING FOR A LITTLE
BIT BUT I DON'T HAVE THAT THAT
ESTIMATE FROM ME BUT I MEAN THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE WHO QUESTIONS
HOUSE AT BECAUSE I WAS HE ABOUT
THE FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE I
HEREBY WILL BE CHARGED HERE BY
THE FINANCIAL AID.
HERE BUT SOMETHING ELSE AND
SOMETHING ELSE AND SO I'M I'M
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH OF MOST STUDENTS REALLY
PAYING.
AND AND IS IT REASONABLE TO SAY
THAT WE ARE CHARGING TUITION.
AND THEN PAYING FOR AT THE SAME
TIME.
YOU KNOW --
SO THAT.
WE'RE GIVING THE STUDENTS WHAT
WE CHARGING AN EXACT AND A
REALIZATION OF THAT UNTIL OF
SOMEONE MENTION WELL THOUGH.
FINANCIAL VIA TUITIONS WILL
INCREASE BUT DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT BECAUSE WE GOT A CUP IN
FINANCE RIGHT.
SOME SAM WILL WHY WOULD WE
INCREASE THE TUITION IF YOU ARE
GOING TO TURN AROUND AND PUT IT
FINANCIAL AID THIS GOT PAPER I
MEAN.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU'RE
ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS --
AND THE LAST POINT THAT I WAS
MAKING ABOUT TRANSPARENCY OF
INFORMATION AND BEING ABLE.
TO GET PRECISELY THE ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE POSING
IN IS EXACTLY WHAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND WE THINK THAT THERE
ARE CERTAIN METRICS.
THAT ARE NOT.
EASILY UNDERSTOOD AND THEY'RE
NOT UNDERSTOOD ACROSS SYSTEMS SO
HOW CAN WE ACTUALLY BRING SOME
TRANSPARENCY AND SOME --
UNIFORMITY TO THE WAY IN WHICH
WE MEASURE THE SING SO NUMBER
ONE I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE THE
FACTORS ARE --
LATE.
AND THEN ASKING BOLD QUESTIONS
LIKE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN FACT
IF WE WERE TO GIVE THE FINANCIAL
THEY GIVE THAT MONEY BACK TO THE
SYSTEM WHAT DOES THAT DO TO
TUITION.
I MEAN OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THE TUITION
INCREASES WOULD BE AND THEN WHAT
WOULD BE THE PUBLIC RESPONSE TO
THAT BUT THOSE ARE EXACTLY THE
KINDS OF ANSWERS THAT WE THINK
SHOULD BE AUSTIN AND ANSWERED
AND THE NEXT.
PANEL OF COURSE IS GOING.
TO PICK THIS UP BEEN THOSE OF
THE EXPERTS.
THAT OF COURSE FINANCIALLY
DOESN'T COVER TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE WHICH IS THE OTHER
THING THAT WE NEED TO BE.
FRONT VERY THOUGHTFUL OF BUT I
LOVE MY THING IS THAT IF IF WE
GET AWAY FINANCE WAITING GAVE
THE MONEY TO THE INSTITUTIONS.
THE FEES WOULD DECREASE NOT
INCREASE BECAUSE THAT MONEY
WOULD GO TO BASICALLY DO WHAT
IT'S DOING NOT ME.
IT YOU GIVING THAT MONEY TO THE
STUDENTS TO GIVE TO THE
UNIVERSITIES OR WHOMEVER
WHATEVER THIS IS AND SO THAT
MONEY THEN IT'S LIKE.
WE GAVE OUR MONEY THEY TURN ON
GAVE IT BACK TO THE INSTITUTION
THAT WE COULD HAVE GIVEN TO
DIRECTLY. TO EDUCATE KIDS SO
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING YOU KNOW I
MEAN IT'S IT'S IT'S I WAS A FAKE
NEWS A FAKE INFORMATION BECAUSE
THIS TO POLITICAL BUT HAVE --
BUT IT'S BUT IT'S IT'S NOT AS
CLEAR AS I IS IT COULD BE MORE
IMPORTANTLY I'M NOT SURE OF IS
THAT THE ACTIVE AS IT SHOULD BE.
A AND IT DOESN'T REALLY GIVE US
A FULL SENSE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN TERMS OF EDUCATING KIDS HOW
MUCH MONEY WERE ACTUALLY PUTTING
INTO THOSE SYSTEMS.
THAT -- AND
THAT MONEY WOULD BE USED TO RUN
THE SYSTEM SO THAT THAT THEY
COULD NOT ALL OF A SUDDEN
INCREASE TUITION.
UP BECAUSE IF THEY WANT INCREASE
TUITION WHEN MAY INCREASE
TUITION WE PAY FOR IT ANYWAY.
OKAY SO AS A RESULT --
YOU KNOW THE MONEY IS STILL THE
IT'S ALL THE SAME MONEY ROAMING
AROUND IN THE SAME POT.
OTHER MAYBE OTHER RESOURCES ARE
BETTER AT PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON THAT WE
FIND IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY BUT
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE THE
CAMPUSES THAT WE HAVE THIS ISSUE
THE UC'S AND OTHERS.
YOU KNOW IF WE IF WE GIVEN THE
BOB GRANT INSTEAD OF GIVING THE
BOB GRANT TO PAY FOR THE SO
CALLED TUITION THAT STUDENTS
HAVE.
FORGIVEN STRUGGLING TO DIRECTLY
TO THE INSTITUTIONS HERE'S THE
MONEY TO RUN THE INSTITUTION AND
ALL.
AND THEN THAT MAY GIVE US A
PERSPECTIVE WE NEED TO CLOSE THE
GAP TO HAVE FREE TUITION
COMPLETELY.
I IN SOME PLACES IT MAY BE CLOSE
IN SOME COMMITTEE COLLEGES A C.
ISSUE SO I STILL HAVE SOME GAPS
THAT OF THE YEAR.
THAT ARE MADE UP BY FEDERAL
GRANTS AND SO FORTH AND SO ON
BUT BUT IT JUST SEEMS STRANGE TO
ME THAT WE ARE AN INSTITUTION
THAT WE HAVE THESE UNIVERSITIES.
AND THAT WE HAVE THE SPECIES WE
CHARGE THEM AND THEN WE PAY FOR
THOSE FEES UP WITH FINANCIAL AID
A CLEARLY SOME STUDENTS DON'T
QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL AID.
AND THAT MAY BE A VARIABLE IN
DETERMINING WHAT STUDENTS PAY IF
WE PAY FOR EVERYTHING WHAT
STUDENTS WHICH STUDENTS WHO
WOULD WEBSITE INCOME HAVE TO PAY
ADDITIONAL FEES OR SOMETHING.
THAT MIGHT BE THERE BUT IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE IT'S IT'S MONEY
THAT'S GOING IN A CIRCLE.
YOU KNOW AND AND AS A RESULT I'M
NOT SURE WITH THAT AS EFFECTIVE
AS WE COULD BE IN PLANNING THAT
MONEY.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS WE
THINK WE SHOULD DO IN ORDER TO
FINANCE THE SYSTEM.
AND I I DID WANT TO NOTE TWO
THINGS --
THAT I WON IT BY UNDERSTOOD
WHATEVER QUESTIONS WAS.
NOW AFTER FINANCIAL AID WHAT IT
ACTUALLY COST UNITS TO GO TO
COLLEGE IN THERE ARE ESTIMATES
OF THAT AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
TABLE IN THE NEXT PANEL THAT
THAT SHOWS COST PER STUDENT SO
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY REVIEW
THAT TABLE THAT MIGHT.
GET AT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE IN THAT AT GUESS THAT DEALS
WITH BOOKS MAYBE I'M LEFT FEES
OCCASIONALLY RIGHT BUT BUT WE
PROBABLY PAY LAB FEES IF WE PUT
THE MONEY IN IT.
A WE MAY HAVE TO PAY ME AT THE
PAPER BOOKS AND OF COURSE IF
THEY DON'T LIVE ON CAMPUS THAT
HAVE TO PAY FOR LODGING.
OKAY I ASSUME SO OF THAT THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT TO
ME WE NEED CELLS IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE CURRENTLY FINANCING IT
RATHER THAN.
JUST FIGURED WE NEED TO FIND
SOME MORE REVENUE SOMEWHERE ELSE
WHICH WOULD PROBABLY DO BUT ALSO
YOU KNOW HAVING A A SPECIAL FUND
FOR THE RAINY DAY.
BECAUSE WILL PROBABLY NEVER HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY IN THE RAINY DAY
FUND TO ACTUALLY.
HAVE A REAL RAIN ON US A AND SO
--
THAT BECOMES A REAL CHALLENGE
BUT BUT I I'M I'M JUST I'M I'M
I'M ALWAYS IN ALL OF THE
FINANCIAL A PIECE BECAUSE AND
THOSE SYSTEMS THAT ARE THERE
BECAUSE THEY SEEM TO BE ALIVE
ONE HAND GIVEN TO THE EXPAND.
AND IT ENDS UP WITH A THIRD HAND
WHICH IS WHAT WE WANTED TO GO IN
FIRST PLACE.
AND ALL AND I'M JUST THINKING
WHY DID WE DO ALL THAT.
YOU KNOW JUST TO GIVE THE MONEY
BACK TO THE INSTITUTIONS IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
YOU KNOW HOUSING THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS HERE THAT THAT'S THERE
BUT YOU KNOW IS SELLING EUROPE
WITH CERTAIN PEOPLE HAVE FREE
TUITION.
JUST DON'T CHARGING TUITION GIVE
MONEY TO THE INSTITUTIONS WHERE
THEY'RE GOING RATHER THAN GIVE
IT TO THEM SO THEY COULD PAY
THEIR DREAM ACT FUNNY OR
WHATEVER IT IS AND COME BACK
AROUND IN THE DIFFERENT KIND OF
WAY.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE A TREMENDOUS
WASTE OF ENERGY BUT ALSO NOT
VERY CLEAR TO US.
WITH HOW MUCH WE ARE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING WELL THANK YOU DR
WEBER FOR DOING A GREAT JOB OF
CLEANING UP OUR NEXT PANEL --
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THIS PANEL
VERY MUCH FOR FOR COMING IN
CHATTING WITH US TODAY AND ALL
THE INFORMATION YOU PROVIDED
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT PANEL WILL BE ON
FINANCING STUDENT AID IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE WITH JENNIFER KUHN --
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOLLOWED BY THE PEAK THEIR
CORTEZ ON CALL ON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA'S TO
NAY COMMISSION.
AND ROBERT CHARMIN SENIOR FELLOW
AT THE CENTURY FOUNDATION THANKS
ALSO MUCH.
THANK YOU JENNIFER CAN ALLEGE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I YOU SHOULD
HAVE AUTHOR HAND DOWN FOR YOU
FINANCIALLY MAJOR BUDGET TRENDS
--
I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF FUNDING FOR
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I DO THINK IT I MIGHT HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
QUESTIONS THAT YOU JUST TIED SO
STARTING HERE ON PAGE.
ONE IT LOOKS OUT MAJOR
FINANCIALLY DEVELOPMENTS.
THE STATE FIRST PROVIDED
SUBSIDIES DIRECTLY TO THE
INSTITUTION INSTITUTIONS SO IT'S
DONE THIS FOR DECADES.
WHEN THE STATE PROVIDES FUNDING
DIRECTLY TO EACH OF THE
STATEMENTS THAT EFFECTIVELY
REDUCE THOSE TUITION FOR
EVERYONE AYE WHETHER THEY HAVE
FINANCIAL NEED DEMONSTRATED
FINANCIAL NEED?
SO WHEN YOU LOOK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE STATE
SUBSIDIES TO THE STATE TO THE
EACH OF THE SEGMENTS WAS
COVERING 95% OF THE EDUCATION
COSTS AT THE COLLEGES. 68% THAT
CS YOU AND 62% AT UC'S SO THE
STATE SUBSIDIES WERE COVERING UP
A PREPONDERANCE OF COST AT AT
SEVERAL OF THE SEGMENTS.
IN THE MID FIFTIES THE STATE
PROVIDED ITS FIRST TARGETED
FINANCIALLY PROGRAM SO RATHER
THAN GIVING MONEY TO THE
SEGMENTS THAT GAVE IT DIRECTLY
TO FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS.
THE VERY FIRST STATE FUNDED
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON TUITION
ASSISTANCE THAT FOCUSED ON HIGH
COST INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING
PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GOT
INVOLVED IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
CREATING THEIR OWN GRANT AND
LOAN PROGRAMS AND THOSE PROGRAMS
CREATED IN THE SIXTIES ARE THE
PRECURSORS OF WHAT WE HAVE TODAY
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TODAY
HAS A LARGE PROGRAM PROGRAM.
AND ALSO HAS LARGE STUDENT LOAN
PROGRAMS.
IN THE LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
AT THAT POINT THE STATE HAD A
PATCHWORK OF STATE FUNDED
PROGRAM SO IT REPLACE THOSE
PROGRAMS WITH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
AND THE STRUCTURE PUT IN PLACE
FOR THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM IS
LARGELY THE SAME AS IT DOES
TODAY.
SO BACK IN THE LATE SEVENTIES
THE STATE A PROGRAM THAT WOULD
PROVIDE TUITION ASSISTANCE FOR
SORT OF MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS.
CAL GRANT BE WOULD PROVIDE BOTH
TUITION ASSISTANCE AND SOME
LIVING COVERAGE BUT IT WOULD DO
IT FOR THE FINANCIALLY NEEDY OUR
STUDENTS THE LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND THEN THE CAL GRANT SEE WOULD
BE A SPECIALIZED PROGRAM THAT
WOULD HELP THOSE STUDENTS WHO
ARE GOING INTO SHORT TERM HER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES CSU IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
INTRODUCED THEIR OWN
INSTITUTIONAL AID PROGRAMS.
I WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
BUT AT THIS TIME INSTITUTIONAL
I'M EDUCATION FEES ARE BEING
INSTITUTED INSTITUTIONAL AID
PROGRAMS THAT THE COLLEGE AT THE
COMMUNICATIVE ARE INTENDED TO
COVER.
THOSE ON EDUCATION FEES.
SO AT THIS POINT IN TIME OVER
TIME THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAM TRADITIONALLY BECAME
KNOWN AS THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
FEE WAIVER PROGRAM THE CS YOU'VE
INSTITUTIONALLY PROGRAM BECAME
KNOWN AS THE STATE UNIVERSITY
GRANT PROGRAM.
YOU SEE HAD ALREADY HAD AN
INSTITUTIONAL AID PROGRAM IN
PLACE THAN IT HAD COVERED
TUITION AS WELL AS LIVING COST
TRADITIONALLY THAT'S BEEN CALLED
THE UNIVERSITY STUDENT A
PROGRAM.
SO YOU TURN TO PAGE TO IT JUST
HIGHLIGHTS A FEW OTHER MAJOR
DEVELOPMENTS OVER THE DECADE SO
THE STATE.
MADE PROGRAMS AN ENTITLEMENT IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE SO THOSE
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY WHO ARE
COMING STRAIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND ARE WERE ONLY SPENDING A FEW
YEARS OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL BEFORE
GOING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THEN WE'RE COMPLETING OUR
TRANSFER COLLEGE LOWER DIVISION
COURSES THAT COMMUNICATIVE IN
JUST A FEW YEARS TIME.
THOSE WHO ARE TO RETIREMENT THAT
FACT OF LEON AT PRETTY
STREAMLINED PATH TOWARD THE
UNIVERSITY IS WOULD BE ENTITLED
FOR AID.
AND THEN THOSE STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT QUALIFY WOULD BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR A COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM TYPICALLY THEY WOULDN'T
BE ELIGIBLE BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE
OR BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT THEY HAD OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND THEN THE STATEMENT SOME
REFINEMENTS AND TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE TO THAT PROGRAM SEE PROGRAM
JUST REFINING AT TRYING TO
TARGET TO DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
TO CERTAIN HIGH WORKFORCE DEMAND
AREAS.
FROM TWO THOUSAND ONE THROUGH
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE STATE
TOOK OF WRITER OPTIONS TO GIVE
SOME AID OPPORTUNITIES TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS SO OVER
THAT COURSE OF TIME IT PROVIDE
IT ALLOWS YOU STUDENTS TO
QUALIFY FOR RESIDENT TUITION
CHARGES I EACH OF THE SEGMENTS.
THEN AND ALLOW THEM TO QUALIFY
FOR STATE FUNDED AID AND THEN
AND ALLOW THEM TO GET STATE
FUNDED LOANS.
DURING THE RECESSION YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT STATE FUNDING
DROPPING INTUITION CHARGES
INCREASING AND AT THIS TIME
THERE WAS INCREASING CONCERN
WITH MODELING.
INCOME STUDENTS EVEN THOSE WHO
ONE AND HAVE TRADITIONALLY BEEN
DEFINED AS FINANCIALLY NEEDY AND
SO AT THIS POINT IN TIME TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE
STATE PUTS IN PLACE THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
TODAY THAT PROGRAMS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED IT COVERS 40% OF THE
TUITION CHARGE FOR MIDDLE INCOME
STUDENTS WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THEN EVEN MORE RECENTLY THE
NOT JUST THE LAST FEW BUDGET
CYCLES THE STATE HAS CREATED
SOME PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE LIVING
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO DO QUALIFY FOR THE
CAL GRANT BE PROGRAM.
BUT WHO QUALIFY TYPICALLY FOR A
RATHER MODEST LIVING ADJUSTMENT
THIS IS TO PROVIDE THEM A MORE
GENEROUS LIVING GRANT IF THEY GO
FULL TIME.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY TAKE
FIFTEEN OR MORE UNITS TODAY THEY
QUALIFY FOR FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GRANT FUNDS ABOVE THE
CAL GRANT BE ACCESSED THE WORD
ABOUT THE PROGRAM TO FADE OUT
APPLY FOR IT.
PAGE THREE AND FOUR THEN FOCUS
ON MORE DEEPLY WHAT'S HAPPENED
TO TUITION AND FINANCIAL AID
OVER THE YEARS.
SO IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS GOING WAY BACK YOU SEE
HAD THINGS CALLED FEES IT WASN'T
UNTIL THE NINETEEN SEVENTY IS
WHERE THEY CREATED AN EDUCATION
FEET UP OVER THE DECADES OF
VAULT INTO THE TUITION CHART WE
KNOW OF TODAY.
CSU ALSO HAD HISTORY OF COURSE
FEES MATERIAL IN SERVICE FEES
BUT THEY DON'T CREATE THE THOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY FEE UNTIL
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
THE SAUCER HAS EVOLVED OVER TIME
TO BECOME THE TUITION FEE.
THE ISSUE CREATED ITS M.
ENROLLMENT FEE AND NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND ALL OF THESE
CASES THAT EDUCATION FEE HAS
EBBED AND FLOWED WITH THE
ECONOMIC CYCLE INCREASING AS
YOU'VE HEARD LOTS ABOUT DURING
RECESSIONS.
THIS IS TIMES WHEN THE STATE
FUNDS FUNDING US DROPPING IT'S
ALSO THE TIME WHERE FAMILY WAGES
TEND TO BE STAGNATING AND
UNEMPLOYMENT TIMES TO BE
INCREASING.
JUSTIN CONTRAST DURING
RECOVERIES STATE FUNDING IS
INCREASING SO FEES ARE A HALT
FLAT THIS IS ALSO THE TIME WHEN
FAMILY INCOMES TEND TO BE
INCREASING UNEMPLOYMENT
DROPPING.
WHEN YOU LOOKED AT THE PERIOD
THE TWENTY FIVE YEAR PERIOD
STRETCHING FROM NINETEEN NINETY
THROUGH TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
INFLATION ADJUSTED DOLLARS YOU
SEE THAT THE FEE AT UC NC ISSUES
INCREASE FIFTEEN TIMES?
AND AT THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THIRTY FOLD SERVE OBVIOUSLY VERY
STEEP INCREASE AS DESPITE THOSE
INCREASES COMMUNITY COLLEGE FEES
TODAY ARE STILL THE LOWEST IN
THE NATION.
AS CSU IS LOW RELATIVE TO ITS
AND INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
BY CONTRAST UC'S TUITION CHARGES
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN ITS
COMPARABLE INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
HAVE YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR IT
GIVES YOU COMPARABLE INFORMATION
ON AND FINANCIAL AID FOR
UNDERGRADUATES FOR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I TUITION I I'M SORRY SPENDING
ON CAL GRANTS GOES UP AS TUITION
INCREASES TO YOU CAN SEE THOSE
TRENDS.
YOU CAN SEE IN INFLATION
ADJUSTED TERMS FINANCIAL AID
SPENDINGS INCREASED FIVE FOLD
OVER THE PERIOD SO BY TWENTY
FIFTEEN MORE THAN EIGHT BILLION
A SPENT ANNUALLY ON AID.
FOR UNDERGRADUATES.
ALTHOUGH THE NEXT PAGE GETS OUT
SOME OF THE CONVERSATION YOU
WERE HAVING EARLIER WITHIN THAT
PRICE.
AND SO FINANCIAL AID APPEARS TO
BE WORKING GENERALLY AS AN TIME
DEAD WHERE LOWER INCOME STUDENTS
ARE FACING LOWER NET PRICE.
SO WHAT NOT PRICES A MEASURE OF
HIS LOOKING NOT FROM A STUDENT'S
PERSPECTIVE THERE COST OF
ATTENDANCE SO NOT FROM THE
STATE'S PERSPECTIVE BUT FROM THE
STUDENT'S TUITION LEVINE HOW
MUCH DOES IT COST IS IT UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IT'S ABSTRACTS ALL OF THEIR GIFT
DATED AND LOOKS AT HOW MUCH THEN
IS THE PRICE THAT THEY HAVE TO
PAY.
AND I'M THE GRAPHIC AT THE TOP
SHOWS YOU JUST THE INCOME
DISTRIBUTION ACROSS STATES OF
THE CAMPUSES SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
STUDENTS THAT THE COLLEGES.
ARE LOWER INCOME THAN NOT THE
UNIVERSITY IS 67% OF
COMMUNICATIVE STUDENTS FOR
EXAMPLE COME FROM FAMILIES
EARNING LESS THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND A YEAR. FOR THOSE
STUDENTS I'M AND NOT INCOME
RANGE AT THE COLLEGES THEIR PAIN
I'M EITHER OUT OF POCKET OR
THROUGH SOME SORT OF BORROWING
OR WORK EARNINGS FIVE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
DOLLARS THESE ARE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN NUMBERS.
BUT YOU CAN SEE ACROSS ALL OF
THE SEGMENTS THAT AS FAMILY
INCOME GOES UP THAT NIGHT PRICE
GOES THAT THIS IS WHAT YOU
PRESUMABLY WOULD WANT TO SEE
THAT AS FAMILIES.
INCOMES IMPROVE --
THE AMOUNT THAT THEY PAY OUT OF
POCKET INCREASES BUT THAT THE
FINANCIALLY NEEDY OF STUDENTS
ARE PAINT THE LEAST THIS IS A
TREND YOU TO SEE AGAIN ACROSS
ALL OF THE SEGMENTS.
THE REASON NOT NOT PRICE IS AS
LOW AS THAT IS IN CALIFORNIA IS
BECAUSE OF STAMPS SUBSTANTIAL
SHARE OF UNDERGRADUATES TO GET
THEIR FEES COVERED SO 58% OF
UNDERGRADUATES AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALMOST TWO THREE TWO
THIRDS OF THE UNIVERSITIES.
AND THIS IS THE CONVERSATION
AGAIN --
JUST SEN MAY BE A ADDRESS ONE OF
THE ISSUES ITEM IF YOU WERE IF
TO FOR EXAMPLE THINK ABOUT YOU
SEE IN RIGHT NOW THEY'RE CHARGED
AT TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IF
YOU WERE TO SAY HEY LET'S CUT IT
IN HALF TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE ISSUE THERE OBVIOUSLY AS
YOUR NOW CHARGING EVERYBODY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS SOME WHO MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT SO THAT
MIGHT BE THE THING THAT
PROHIBITS THEM FROM GOING TO
COLLEGE.
AND THEN THE FAMILIES WHO WOULD
GO TO COLLEGE REGARDLESS MIGHT
EVEN BE WILLING TO PAY TWICE AS
MUCH AS WE NOW CHARGE THEM THAT
MONEY WOULD EFFECTIVELY BE TAKEN
ON THE SYSTEM.
BUT IF YOU TURN TO THE LAST PAGE
CHAIR IS JUST ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT
FOR DECADES SOME OF THEM ARE
EMERGING SALIENT ISSUES.
THAT KEY AT ONE OF THE KEY
ISSUES THAT YOU'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT ALREADY HAS JUST HOW MUCH
TO PUT DIRECTLY INTO THE
SEGMENTS VERSUS HOW MUCH TO
TARGET TO FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS.
ANOTHER PERENNIAL ISSUE IS ONCE
YOU'VE DETERMINED YOUR POT OF
FINANCIAL AID FUNDING HOW DO YOU
PRIORITIZE NOT AMONG FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS LAST HOW MUCH
ATTENTION DO YOU DEDICATE SET A
TIME OUT OF COLLEGE INCOME AND
ASSETS ACADEMIC CRITERIA.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT SOME
SUGGESTIONS FOR CHANGING SOME OF
THOSE CRITERIA IN AN EFFORT TO
SIMPLIFY AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR
STUDENTS.
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT THAT LATER ON
THE PANEL TODAY.
THE THIRD ISSUE WHICH IS
INCREASING LEAD A HIGH PROFILE
HAS TO DO WITH HOW TO PROVIDE
SO THE STATE HAS A TRADITION OF
PROVIDING SOME LIVING AID FOR
THE LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS BUT
MORE RECENTLY AS TRYING TO
EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF LIVING
COVERAGE THAT IT PROVIDES.
BUT IT'S A LOT OF ISSUES ARE
EMERGING AS IT CONSIDERS THAT'S
HOW MANY YEARS IS IT OKAY IF A
STUDENT IS IN COLLEGE FIVE SIX
SEVEN YEARS WITH THE STATE STILL
COVER LIVING COSTS.
WHAT WOULD BE THE EXPECTATIONS
ON STUDENTS WORKER IN IN SOME
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT STUDENTS
CAN WORK UP TO TWENTY HOURS
WITHOUT NEGATIVE OUTCOMES ON
THEIR EDUCATION WHAT THE STATE
EXPECT THEM TO WORK A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF HOURS?
SOME RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT AS
LONG AS STUDENTS GRADUATE THEY
TEND TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE THEIR
THAT LEVELS THE PROBLEM BECOMES
WHEN STUDENTS GET THREE YEARS
INTO A PROGRAM AND THEN DON'T
COMPLETE AND DON'T HAVE EASY
ACCESS. TO MANAGE THEIR DOT OVER
TIME.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT KINDS
OF LIVING COSTS SHOULD THERE BE
EXPECTATIONS THAT STUDENTS THAT
COME LIVE AT HOME DO SO FOR A
YEAR OR THAT STUDENTS PICK
RELATIVELY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS.
MANY ISSUES HAVE BEEN A MERGING
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COVER LIVING COSTS IN AN
EFFECTIVE WAY.
AND FINALLY YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
MUCH MORE ABOUT HOW COMPLEX THE
SYSTEM HAS GOTTEN FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE FROM STUDENTS
PERSPECTIVES.
SO TRYING TO SIMPLIFY THE SYSTEM
WHILE STILL TAKING INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT NEEDS INTO ACCOUNT SO
WHAT ARE YOUR OPTIONS TO HAVE A
RESPONSIVE SYSTEM THAT STILL
MUCH EASIER TO UNDERSTAND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT
SOME VERY REASONABLE OPTIONS.
THAT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER LATER ON
THE PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE.
THANK AFTERNOON LOOKING BACK
THAT'S LIKE ALLOW BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THE PLEASURE TO BE
HERE AND THANK YOU.
FOR INVITING ME TO THIS OP PANEL
IN THIS HEARING --
FIRST BALL I INCREDIBLY
PRIVILEGED.
TO YOU NAY COMMISSION THAT
ADMINISTERS THAT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND STATE FINANCIAL AID
--
AND TODAY BECAUSE JENNIFER HAVE
GONE OVER SOME OF THE CURRENT
PROGRAMS IN A WAY THE SHOULDN'T
NAME THEM WHICH IS FINE --
BUT WORK I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE
ABOUT THE SHORTCOMINGS AND THEN
WHAT WE ENVISIONED SO I'VE CUT.
I CAN'T AT LEAST MY TESTIMONY AT
LEAST BY ONE THIRD OR SO WAS I
HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL --
VERSO WE HAVE A VERY GENEROUS --
FINANCIALLY THAT --
YOU KNOW IN IT PROGRAM WHICH TWO
BILLION DOLLARS THAT PROVIDES A
AWARDS TO ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND OF COURSE
THE DEMOGRAPHIC OF THE STUDENT
HAS CHANGED OUR LAST FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY YEARS SO WE HAVE.
ALLOT MORE STUDENTS THAT ARE
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME --
THAT ALSO ARE --
OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR OF COURSE
AND WE ARE ENCOURAGING ALL
STUDENTS TO GO ON TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION SO THAT THE
STUDENT TODAY LOOKS DIFFERENT
WORKS MORE AND IT MIGHT EVEN BE
OLDER AND AND MARK
NONTRADITIONAL.
WE ALSO --
HAVE THE PRESTIGE OF OFFERING
CHOICES TO STUDENTS SO THEY CAN
ATTEND THE UC AND CSU COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THEY MEAN IT ATTEND
A PRIVATE FOR PROFIT OR
NONPROFIT A WASP ACCREDITED --
AND SO STUDENTS HAVE THAT CHOICE
WHICH IS UNIQUE AS WELL --
IN OUR STATE.
BUT SOME OF THE SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE ASSERTIVE.
IT HAS TO DO WITH STUDENT DEBT.
FOOD AND HOUSING IN SECURITY NOT
TO MENTION STUDENT COMPLETION
AND SO WE'RE HERE TODAY LIKELY
FOR THAT.
REASON ALONE IF FINANCIAL AID
COVERED EVERYTHING EVERYONE WAS
GRADUATING ON TIME WE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS HEARING
IT'S OVER HERE THAT SORT OF
WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
EXAMINES SORT OF THE SYSTEM AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MODERNIZE IT
TO MEET THE STUDENT TODAY SO.
SOME OF THE SHORTCOMINGS OF THE
CURRENT FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND
YOU SHOULD HAVE A ONE PAGER THAT
TALKS ABOUT FUTURE FINANCIALLY.
AND SO SOME OF THE SHORTCOMINGS
--
POLICE WITH A COMPETITIVE
PROGRAM AND IT'S OUR PROGRAM
THAT REALLY TRIES TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS AND THAT --
ARE YOU KNOW --
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OR OLDER WE
ARE ABOUT 250-007-0050 AWARDS
BUT WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IT WOULD COULD
QUALIFY FOR THAT AWARD TO WE
HAVE A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY.
NOT BEING COVERED THAT COULD BE
COVERED --
WITHOUT A WORD SO THAT'S REALLY
ONLY ABOUT WE ONLY COVER ABOUT
8% OF THE STUDENTS THAT COULD
QUALIFY FOR THAT WORD EVEN
THOUGH WE TALK ABOUT HOW
GENEROUS WE WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL
ENTITLEMENT TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT
WOULDN'T GOING ALL THE NAMES.
BUT WE ARE WE ARE PRETTY
GENEROUS --
ABOUT THOSE AND THEN OF COURSE
WE HAVE THE BE IT CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS WORD IN THIS IS PRIMARILY
THE THE A FINANCIAL AID THAT
PROVIDES FOR LIVING EXPENSES.
IT WE PROVIDE ABOUT THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO DOLLARS FOR
A FULL TIME STUDENT --
AND OF COURSE WE MAKE IT A
GUARANTEE IF THE COMING OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL OR GOING DOING A
TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT BUT OF
COURSE THOSE STUDENTS ON THE
COMPETITIVE LIST.
ONLY GET THAT ABOUT ONLY 8% OF
THOSE ACTUALLY ARE AWARDED THAT
NOW IF THAT WOULD THAT AMOUNT
WOULD HAVE KEPT.
KEPT UP WITH THE PRICE OF
INFLATION IT WOULD BE WORTH SIX
THOUSAND TODAY.
SO SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO SHOULD
REALLY BE WORTH SIX THOUSAND
THAT COST QUITE A BIT OF MONEY
TO TO FUND THAT AND THAT'S KIND
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING TODAY.
SO IN ADDITION --
WE ALSO WE SAW ONE OF OUR
PROPOSALS AS PART OF AND I KNOW
THAT --
ROBERT HARDMAN HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT XIN --
AND THE REPORT THAT WE
COMMISSION THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE LED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY --
THAT YOU KNOW WE REALLY BELIEVE
THAT NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS TO
SUPPORT AN INCREASE IN THE BE
ACCESS AWARD WHICH WOULD HELP
FUND SOME OF THAT TUITION AND
LIVING EXPENSES THAT --
STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY SUFFERING
FROM.
SO THERE'S ALSO A GAP --
LET ME THEY WITH THE GAP IS.
SO WE'VE AYE AYE I THINK WE
AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
THAT IT'S INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE ATTACK TRY.
TO HELP AND AND INCENTIVIZE SORT
OF THE CAL GRANT AND SO FOR
STUDENTS OF FAMILIES A FOR THAT
MAKE UP TO FIFTY THOUSAND YOU
CAN HAVE A TWO POINT OH GPA AND
GET A CAL GRANT WHICH MEASURE
TUITION AND FEES.
NOW FOR STUDENTS THAT --
A FAMILY FOR THE MAKES ABOUT
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A THREE POINT NO.
BUT ANY STUDENT IN BETWEEN THE
TWO POINT OR THROUGH PUERTO THAT
LET'S SAY IS IN THE SIXTY
THOUSAND RANGE GETS NOTHING.
NOTHING FROM THE STATE RIGHT AND
SO THERE'S THERE'S DEFINITELY A
GAP IN A NEED TO SORT OF FILL
THAT GAP --
AND SO --
AND IT WAS IT WASN'T INCLUDED TO
HELP INCENTIVIZE OF COURSE --
INTO TO TO ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO
GET --
INCLUDE GET HIGHER GPA SO
CONSIDER THIS FOR IT FOR A
FAMILY FOR THE EARNED SIXTY
THOUSAND HALF OF WHAT ECONOMISTS
SAY HOUSEHOLD NEEDS TO EARN TO
AFFORD AN APARTMENT IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR SAN MATEO.
THE STUDENT YOU KNOW COULD EARN
BELOW THREE POINT NO AND WOULD
GET NOTHING TO IT SO CLEARLY
THERE IN THE NEED BUT THEY THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE THAT UP
OPPORTUNITY FIRST YEAR OF
TUITION FOR CAL GRANT BE
STUDENTS AND SO I KNOW IT'S
GOING AND GETTING COMPLICATED
HERE BUT PURSUES.
SET DID EARNED THAT LIVING AND
TUITION THAT THE LIVING EXPENSES
PORTION THE BE ACCESS AWARD IN
ADDITION TO THAT TUITION FEES
FOR THEIR FIRST YEAR.
THEY DON'T GET ANYTHING FROM THE
STATE --
GOING TO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
THEY GET IN THE SECOND THIRD AND
FOURTH YEAR.
UP BUT THEY DO GET THAT SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE FIRST YEAR FOR
LIVING EXPENSES NOW.
THE UC ISSUES YOU MAY --
PROVIDE THAT TUITION BUT YOU
KNOW I DON'T MUCH OF THE PRIVATE
POLLARD WHOM BUT OF THE STATE
DOESN'T PROVIDED.
AND SO THIS --
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED --
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND
THAT NEVER CHANGE BECAUSE THEY
ASSUME THAT ALL CAL GRANT
BEESTON'S WERE ACTUALLY GOING TO
COMMUNICABLE IT.
AND WORK GOING STRAIGHT INTO A
FOUR YEAR SO THAT'S ANOTHER --
SORT OF IOWA STATE EASY FIX BUT
COULD BE FIXED AND TO PROVIDE
THE STUDENTS THAT FOR YOUR
COVERAGE.
SO THE FUTURE SO WHAT WHAT WE
ENVISION.
A SO WE ENVISION A SYSTEM THAT
ADDRESSES THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE A BEYOND JUST TUITION
AND FEES AS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
TO YOU ABOUT HERE TODAY.
LETTING BECAUSE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH LIVING EXPENSES
HAS OUTPACED THE RISING TUITION
AND FEES COSTS.
SO ONE OF THE THE COMMISSIONERS
AND MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITIES AS
FOR THAT STILL NEED COMMISSION
IS TO REINSTATE THAT SEARS
SURVEY WHICH IS THAT STUDENT
EXPENSE AND RESOURCES SURVEY TO
REALLY FIND OUT.
HOW MUCH OUR STUDENTS PAYING FOR
AND SO AT ALL FIVE SEGMENTS AND
SO IT WAS SUSPENDED AND THAT TWO
THOUSAND SIX SEVEN BECAUSE OF
BUDGET CUTS AND WE'VE
REINSTITUTED IT --
THIS LAST SPRING WE DID A PILOT
AND WE DID A PILOT AT OVER FIFTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND ALL PROVIDE YOU SOME
PRELIMINARY EVIDENCE WE ARE
GOING TO DO THE LARGER ONE THIS
NOVEMBER WITH ALL FIVE SEGMENTS
BUT I CAN LET YOU KNOW NOW THAT
THE PILOT SURVEY DID FIND
HOUSING AND FOOD.
OF WAS SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN
WHAT THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX
WAS SUGGESTING SWITCH REALLY
THING WE WOULD DO SINCE I WAS
SIX OR SEVEN IT INCREASE IT BY
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX AND
CLEARLY.
THAT WASN'T KEEPING UP AND SO I
CAN TELL YOU NOW THAT --
THAT WE WERE OFF.
BUT WITH FOODS AND FOOD AND
HOUSING FOR SHORE --
AND SO I WERE REALLY SCIENTISTS
ARE REINSTITUTE OUT WE ALSO --
I MENTIONED EARLIER WE
COMMISSIONED A REPORT AND A
RUBBER SHARMAN GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT TODAY OF THE THROUGH
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION.
AND THE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT --
WE'RE SUPPORTING WHICH IS A
VISION FOR FINANCIALLY THAT
STREAMLINES IT MAKES IT A SINGLE
STATE GRANT AID PROGRAM A IT
MAKES OVERALL COST OF ATTENDANCE
MANAGEABLE FOR LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS.
BY REDUCING THE NEED TO RELY AND
LOAN THAT INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF AID TO STUDENTS WITH HIGHEST
OVERALL NEED AND DOUBLING DOWN
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY.
AND THOUGH IT WOULD CLOSE UP
SOME OF THOSE GAPS SO THE FIRST
PHASE OF IT INCREASE THE BE
ACCESS WORK LIVING EXPENSES THE
SECOND PHASE FOR US.
AND IN OREGON THE COMMISSIONERS
HAVE SUPPORTED IS A THANKLESS
CONSOLIDATED MAKE IT EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND MUSIC EASIER TO
COMMUNICATE --
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
A BNC TWO POINT A THREE POINT
OPEN UP THE FIRST YEAR BUT IN
THE SECOND YOU KNOW AND SO I WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO EASILY
UNDERSTAND.
AND THEN THE THIRD PART REALLY.
IS -- AND
THEN BRINGING IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
SMALLER BUT A FIRST THOUGHT SO
WE EXPAND THE CAL GRANT AND SO
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR FIRE FIVE
SITE HIGHER ITS EGGMAN TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT COULD LOOK
LIKE WHAT WITH THAT WOULD COST
--
BUT THEN LESLIE REALLY IS YOU
KNOW THERE'S A DESIRE BY IT
DEFINITELY SOME OF THE SEGMENTS
HIGHER ED SEGMENTS AS YOU KNOW
THAT'S JUST RESTOCKING THE BACK
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER SAID
ON THE TITANIC.
DOESN'T REALLY BENEFIT COMMITTEE
COSTUMES FOR INSTANCE BECAUSE
THEY IT WE HAVE A TIERED SYSTEM.
OF ADMISSION AND FINANCIAL AID.
SO THE HIGH THE MORE PRESTIGE
THAT INSTITUTION THE MORE
FINANCIAL AID WE PROVIDE THE
INSTITUTION AND THAT STUDENT AND
SO GUESS WHO GETS LEFT OUT.
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
RIGHT THEY DON'T GET AS MUCH AID
AND I KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR HAS DONE SO
MUCH MORE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISES LAST.
YEAR AT TO TO REALLY BOOST THAT
AND AND A AN INCREASE THAT.
BUT IN ADDITION I HAD MENTIONED
CAL GRANT SEEN THOSE OUR
STUDENTS SEEKING A CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
WE UP UNTIL RECENTLY PROVIDED
THEM LITERALLY FOR AN ENTIRE
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS
WITH UP TO TWO THOUSAND BUT IT'S
A LESS THAN THE SEVEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO SO SOMEHOW THEY'RE
EDUCATION IS VALUED LAUGHS.
AS A HOW TO INCORPORATE THEM IN
THIS OVERHAUL SO THE THIRD PHASE
IS REALLY AN OVERHAUL AND
PROVIDING A REGIONALIZED
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION.
AND RETHINKING HOW WE ADMINISTER
FINANCIALLY TOTALLY BESIDE JUST
CONSOLIDATING IN MAKING EASIER
TO UNDERSTAND REALLY.
WHAT SHOULD WE DO WITH REGARDS
TO PROVIDING A TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE TO A STUDENT?
SIMILAR SORT OF CANADA AS
WITCHES HAY ALL STERN BRING IN
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND AFTER THAT DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU WANT TO GO ALL
STUDENTS WITH AN EXPECTED PATH.
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION ACTS GET
THIS AND YOU CAN TAKE IT WHERE
YOU NEED TO GO WHEREVER IT'S A
HIGH QUALITY FOR BUSCA
ACCREDITED INSTITUTION AND SO.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WHAT.
AND WE WILL HOPE TO HAVE ON THAT
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION IN
SEPTEMBER AND THEN BRING IT OF
COURSE TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION WE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN HAPPEN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO SING THOSE RESULTS --
THEN MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND ROBERT CHAIRMAN I'M
A SENIOR FELLOW AT THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION A OF A PROGRESSIVE
THINK TANK THAT THAT WORKS ON
EDUCATION LABOR IN A VARIETY OF
OTHER.
OTHER ISSUES --
I AM A BORN AND RAISED
CALIFORNIAN --
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY --
TO TO TESTIFY TODAY --
WE DID A DEEP DIVE INTO --
CALIFORNIA IS A FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM DURING THE WINTER --
WHICH WAS IN RESPONSE TO A
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION TO IDENTIFY WAYS FOR
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA SUGGEST METHODS FOR
STREAMLINING AND CONSOLIDATING
PROGRAM.
PROGRAMS --
FINDING STRATEGIES TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE THE NEED TO RELY ON
STUDENT LOAN DEBTS WE CONFERRED
WITH --
EVERYBODY WE COULD IN A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME --
THE STOOD NAY COMMISSION AND
STAFF WERE VERY GENEROUS WITH
THEIR TIME AND WITH THE OUR
HUNDREDS OF QUESTIONS TO THEM
AND TO AND ASKING THEM TO LEAD
US THROUGH EXCRUCIATING DETAIL
OF EXACTLY HOW THINGS.
OPERATE AND AND AND SHOW US WHAT
WHAT DATA THEY HAVE WHAT THEY
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE --
TO REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THAT
THAT TIME AND I'M AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TO PULL
TOGETHER SOME EXPERTS FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND TO TAKE
TAKE A LOOK.
AT CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM OF
FINANCIAL AID ARE GENERAL
FINDINGS WERE --
IN IN SOME SENSE GOOD NEWS FOR
CALIFORNIA IT COMPARED TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY CALIFORNIA
DOES A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF MAKING
SURE THAT.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS MIDDLE
INCOME STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID EITHER THROUGH CAL
GRANTS OR THROUGH INSTITUTIONAL
AID OR SOME COMBINATION SO I'M
WE WE SHOULD TAKE SOME PRIDE IN
THAT -- AT
THE SAME TIME WE DID FIND THAT
MORE AID MORE GRANT AID IS
NEEDED ESPECIALLY TO ADDRESS NON
TUITION EXPENSES AND ESPECIALLY
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHERE
THE THE AID PROGRAMS ARE ARE --
JUST NOT NOT AVAIL I IN THE
SEGMENTS WE ALSO FOUND A SERIOUS
LACK OF COORDINATION AMONG THE
VARIOUS PIECES OF THIS FINANCIAL
AID PUZZLE THAT MAKES THINGS
HARD FOR STUDENTS AND FOR
ANYBODY IN.
INVOLVED IN THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE PROGRAM WHETHER THAT IS
--
FOLKS AT K. TWELVE SCHOOLS WHO
WERE TRYING TO PROVIDE GPA
INFORMATION TO FOLKS OUT WORKING
IN -- THE
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES AT
COLLEGES AND A AND UNIVERSITIES.
WE SUGGESTED --
WE'VE OUR RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
THAT CALIFORNIA ADOPT A A NEW
FRAMEWORK --
TO TO ITS A FINANCIAL AID
FUNDING SIMPLIFYING THE SYSTEM
ELIMINATING A LOT OF THAT THE
RED RED TAPE.
UP BY HAVING ONE CAL GRANT WE
INSIST.
I DIDN'T PUT THIS ON THE SLIDE
BUT WE THOUGHT OF THIS AS KIND
OF A SPREAD AND STACK APPROACH
SO.
ALL ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
A ELIGIBLE BASED ON THEIR NEED
FOR A CAL GRANT --
PLUS THE INSTITUTIONAL AID GOING
ON TOP OF THAT.
AIMING TOWARD AND AFFORDABILITY
TARGET THE AFFORDABILITY TARGET
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION UP ALL
OF THE STUDENTS IS STUDENTS
EXPENSES TUITION TUITION AND
FEES BUT ALSO LIVING EXPENSES
BOOKS TRANSPORTATION AND WHICH
REALLY ARE THE AREAS WHERE WE
ARE MOST LACKING IN THE STATE IN
TERMS OF IN TERMS OF SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS.
AGAIN ESPECIALLY AT THE
COMMUNITY --
BUT THAT THE US DID NAY
COMMISSION AND COLLEGES WOULD BE
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP TO MAKE
SURE THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE
ENOUGH GRANT AID WHERE THEY DO
NOT HAVE TO EITHER TAKE OUT THE
EXCESSIVE AMOUNTS OF LOANS.
OR WORK TOO MUCH IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
AS A PART OF ALL OF THAT --
WE RECOMMEND SHIFTING FROM A
SOLELY A TUITION FOCUS IN TERMS
OF THE CAL GRANT SO THAT THE
OVERARCHING GOAL IS NOT JUST
TUITION COVERAGE BUT COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY.
I THINK IT'S USEFUL --
TO AT I REALLY ENJOY DOCTOR
WEBBER'S QUESTION.
AND HAVE HAD --
IT IT IT WAS USEFUL TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO THINK
ABOUT HOW HOW TO ADDRESS IT
BECAUSE IT WAS A HUGE QUESTION
BUT ALSO KIND OF THE RIGHT
QUESTION.
BECAUSE YOU YOU CERTAINLY COULD
IMAGINE A SYSTEM WHERE THE
STATE.
PROVIDED FUNDING TO INSTITUTIONS
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE INSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT THAT
STUDENTS NEED.
AND TO PROVIDE STUDENTS TO
PROVIDE EITHER ALL STUDENTS OR
POTENTIALLY STUDENTS WITH NEED
WITH --
LIVING EXPENSES SUPPORT --
OF BOOKS AT SET RIGHT NOW
OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD BE VERY
VERY EXPENSIVE FOR THE STATE TO
PAY FOR ALL OF THAT.
FOR EVERY UP RESIDENT INTERESTED
IN IT AND ENROLLING IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
BUT IF YOU BACK AWAY FROM THAT
MODEL AND SAY WELL WHAT IF WHAT
THE STATE WAS COMMITTING TO WAS
SUPPORTING A ENOUGH GRANT TAPE
SO THAT ALL OF THOSE STUDENTS.
I EDUCATIONS WOULD BE AFFORDABLE
GIVEN THEIR ABILITY TO PAY.
THAT IS CLOSER TO WHAT WE SORT
OF HAVE AS A SYSTEM NOW AND THE
SYSTEM THAT WE ARE RECOMMENDING
BE -- THAT
THAT THAT THAT THE UP GAPS BE
FILLED --
AND SIMPLE OUR APPROACHES TO
GETTING INFORMATION ABOUT A BE
CREATED SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE.
EVERYBODY CAN GO TO COLLEGE IT
WILL BE AFFORDABLE FOR THEM
IT'LL BE AFFORDABLE --
THAT PREDICTABLY AFFORDABLE FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF EVEN EVEN
THEIR CHANGING ECONOMIC FAMILY
ECONOMIC SITUATION SO THAT WHEN
WHEN WE HAVE A RECESSION --
AID GOES UP TO SO THAT IT SO
THAT IT BECOMES AN AFFORDABLE
KIND OF APPROACH SO THAT'S WHAT
WE AIM FOR IN KIND OF A THREE
STEP --
APPROACH WITH THE WITH A FIRST
STEP BEING LET'S BOLSTER THAT
CAL GRANT BE AWARD TO ADDRESS
THE BIGGEST HOLE THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW BUT GIVEN THAT WE'RE
TALKING KIND OF MASTER PLAN AND
LONG TERM --
THAT LOOK THAT OVERARCHING GOAL
OF LET'S MAKE SURE THAT.
A QUALITY COLLEGE EDUCATION IS
AFFORDABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS AND RESIDENTS --
IS ACHIEVABLE.
WE WANTED TO ALSO EMPHASIZE SOME
THINGS THAT --
THAT.
COULD BE DONE.
BUT ARE NOT --
DON'T NECESSARILY REQUIRE UP A
LARGE AMOUNT OF FUNDING SO IN MY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THAT I
PROVIDED --
TALKED ABOUT PROVIDING EARLY
FINANCIAL AID INFORMATION.
AFFORDABILITY INFORMATION THAT
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION CAL
GRANTS AS WELL AS INSTITUTIONAL.
AID IF WE WERE TO MOVE ALL OF
THE INTER COMMUNICATION
INTERACTIONS THAT OCCUR.
UP RIGHT NOW BETWEEN ROUGHLY UP
SEPTEMBER OF A OF A STUDENTS
HIGH SCHOOL YEAR --
IF THE BAND AND THE SIX OR NINE
MONTHS AYE AFTER THAT IF WE WERE
TO MOVE WITH THAT LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THIS
DEBATE COMMISSION AND THOSE
STUDENTS.
A YEAR OR TWO YEARS EARLIER.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY HAVE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD COMPARE.
COST TO THEM AT A CSU CAMPUS A
UC CAMPUS A PRIVATE COLLEGE
CAMPUS --
SHOW THEM THEIR OPTIONS HELP
THEM TO MAKE.
DECISIONS THAT WOULD WORK WELL
FOR THEM GIVEN THEIR BACKGROUNDS
GIVEN THEIR INTERESTS HELPING TO
PLAN FOR COLLEGE BETTER --
WITHOUT INCREASING OUR COSTS
FROM WHAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
RIGHT NOW SO --
I STILL I I SOMETIMES WORRY THAT
THE FOCUS ON PUTTING MORE MONEY
INTO FINANCIAL AID --
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO TO
ADDRESS COMPLEXITY AND
INFORMATION THAT WOULD IMPROVE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING NOW IT'S NOT ENOUGH
IT'S NOT WITH US SOLUTION --
BUT I THINK IT'S USEFUL TO KIND
OF MOVE ON BOTH TRACKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I MISSED MEDINA CHAIRMAN DANA.
BUT THANK YOU TO THE PANEL FOR
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND I DO
THINK A LOT OF INTERESTING
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
--
BY DOCTOR WEBER AND AND WHEN I
THINK ABOUT FINANCIAL AID I DO
THINK ABOUT [inaudible]
ACCESSIBILITY.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE CHANGING
CALIFORNIA.
AND CERTAINLY COLLEGE HAS
CHANGED OVER THE YEARS OF WHO
GOES TO COLLEGE WHO CAN GO TO
COLLEGE WHO THINKS ABOUT
COLLEGE.
RIGHT IF WE GO BACK THE
BEGINNING OF YOU SEE.
YOU KNOW IT WAS ONLY.
I THINK A SPECIAL A SMALL GROUP
OF FOLKS WHO COULD AFFORD OR
THOUGHT ABOUT GOING TO COLLEGE
AND CERTAINLY.
THAT IS CHANGE OVER TIME WHERE
NOW WE TALK ABOUT ACCESSIBILITY
MAKING COLLEGE AFFORDABLE TO
ALL.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT COME
TO MIND --
HOW ARE WE DIFFERENT HOUSES
STATE A CALIFORNIA DIFFERENT?
FROM SAY AN INSTITUTION LIKE
HARVARD OR STANFORD WHO HAS I
BELIEVE.
NO PROBLEM WITH MONEY.
FROM WHAT I'VE READ.
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S YOU DIDN'T
LIKE STANFORD AND HARVARD HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO FUND.
ALL STUDENTS WHO ATTEND.
RIGHT AND SO WE I THINK YOU KNOW
I'VE NEVER ATTENDED STANFORD OR
HARVARD --
BUT THEY'RE ABLE TO FIND.
WHATEVER STUDENT COMES THROUGH
THEIR DOOR --
HOW'RE HOW'RE HOW IS FINANCIAL
AID IN CALIFORNIA DIFFERENT FROM
THAT -- IT.
CAN WE TRY THAT.
WELL NOT NOT ALL CALIFORNIA.
A PRIVATE STAR LIKE HARVARD AND
STANFORD NO OUT OF STATE HOUSING
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL AID --
DIFFERENT WHITWICK WE'RE TRYING
TO ALLOW.
CALIFORNIA AND TO HAVE AXES TO
SEE IT YOU YOU SEE AND PRIORITY
ISSUE.
AND AND AND IT AT FIRST I I
WILL.
THOUGHT OF ASKING THE QUESTION
ARE BY NUMBERS YOU KNOW --
HOW MANY CALIFORNIANS?
THE DO WE HAVE A NUMBER REVIEW
IF I WROTE DOWN THE NUMBER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN FINANCIALLY
WE AWARD FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
AWARDS.
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY INSTITUTIONS.
THE INSTITUTIONS ARE OVER FIVE
SECONDS CSU YOU SEE HOW MANY
COLLEGES FOR PROFIT.
PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT PRIVATE
BUT THEY ALL HAVE TO BE WHAT'S
GOOD CREDIT SO AT A PRIVATE.
BRANSON'S WHAT'S COMPETITIVE.
NONPROFIT A STUDENT CAN RECEIVE
ABOUT NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
TUITION AND FEES AS COMPARED TO
THE UC OR CSU TUITION AND FEES
WHICH IS.
WHAT ABOUT ALMOST SIX THOUSAND
IT CSU AND ABOUT UP TWELVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY OR
SO I THINK SIXTY DOLLARS LESS --
AT UC. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS YES AND I WROTE DOWN
58% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
DID I HEAR THAT YOU KNOW HOW
THAT THAT NUMBER AND GET TUITION
AND DON'T PAY THEIR EDUCATION.
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND IN FACT
HAVE 50% FIFTY EIGHT A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN THAT IN UNIT REYES
THAT STILL I DON'T PAY ANYTHING
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHAT WOULD
IT WHAT IS THE PERCENTAGE OF C
AND CSU STUDENTS.
THAT --
RECEIVED FINANCIALLY.
HIGHER SO 67% THAT'S THE ISSUE
AND 66% AT UC SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY
SIX HAVE SOME FINANCIALLY.
YES AM EVEN NOT YOU'VE SEEN THE
WAY BECAUSE I AM.
SYPHAC HERE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT CAL GRANT PROGRAMS SO
THERE'S TWO BILLION FOR CAL
GRANTS THERE'S ANOTHER TO SOME
BILLION.
IN TUITION REVENUE AT THE
UNIVERSITY'S THAT'S BEING
REDIRECTED AND AID AND THEN
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF FEDERAL
MONEY.
SO WHEN YOU TALK TO YOU SEE FOR
EXAMPLE THEY HAVE A PARTICULAR
EIGHT MODEL THAT SAYS IF.
WHATEVER YOUR FAMILY CAN
CONTRIBUTE LET'S HARLEM ACTUALLY
THEY THEY SET THIS UNIFORM WORK.
LOAN EXPECTATION AND THEN THEY
COVER THE RESIDUAL UP TO THE
COST OF ATTENDANCE AT THE COST
OF ATTENDANCE AT BERKELEY AS
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND THEY
EXPECT EVERYBODY THROUGH MARK IN
LOANS TO DO.
EIGHT THOUSAND LET'S SAY I THINK
IT'S A LITTLE BIT HIGHER THE
STATE'S LET'S MAKE IT TEN
THOUSAND THEY WILL.
I COME UP WITH THAT EIGHT
REMAINING EIGHTEEN THOUSAND SO
THAT THE STUDENT CAN IN THERE OF
PERSPECTIVE RECENTLY MANAGE
BILLY IT'S HAPPENED.
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
AT IS THAT SOME WHAT THE
QUESTION THE DOCTOR WEBER PASSED
--
AND IT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION
TO ME I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT OF
STUDENT --
FINANCIAL AID AS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE STUDENT
WHO COULD ATTEND AND NOT ATTEND.
BUT THAT'S HOW I THOUGHT OF IT
OR HOW I THINK OF IT.
YOU KNOW THAT WITHOUT FINANCIAL
AID.
X. NUMBERS STUDENTS WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO ATTEND.
YOU SEE SERIOUS.
OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE --
THAT IS CORRECT [inaudible]
SO BY.
BUT BUT BUT IS --
SYSTEM A DIFFERENT SYSTEM IS
THAT IT IS VERY DIFFERENT SYSTEM
THAT WOULD ALLOW --
ACCESSIBILITY TO ALL THESE
NUMBERED THESE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS --
TO TO ATTEND COLLEGE.
BUT WITHOUT FINANCIALLY.
OUR MAN I KNOW I AM NOT AWARE OF
ANYTHING THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO ATTEND WITHOUT FINANCIAL AID
A AT LEAST EQUALITY --
ENOUGH INSTITUTION OUT THERE ARE
MANY MOVING PARTS OF ALL OF THIS
--
YOU CAN HAVE A VERY LOW QUALITY
INSTITUTION WITHOUT A LOT OF
TEACHER STUDENT INTERACTION I
SUPPOSE AND A BUT IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ACCESS. TO QUALITY
INSTITUTIONS OF THE MONEY EITHER
NEEDS TO CALM THE MONEY FOR THE
OPERATIONS OF THE INSTITUTION
EITHER NEEDS TO COME FROM THE
STATE OR FROM TUITION AND IF A
STUDENT CAN'T AFFORD IT THAT THE
TUITION.
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE.
TO GO YOU ALSO NEED TO GUY
CONSIDER THE STUDENTS ADDITIONAL
COSTS SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
ENGAGE IN --
AND FOCUS ON THEIR THEIR
EDUCATION AND NOT BE PULLED AWAY
BY WORK OR FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES SO THAT IT CAN
BE EFFECTIVE AND IN THAT WAY --
THAT THE STANFORD'S IN HARVARD'S
ARE ABLE TO MANAGE --
WITH -- WITH
JEWISH AND BECAUSE THEY ARE
SELECTIVE IN THEIR ADMISSIONS
AND THERE THE THE CRITERIA THEY
USE -- FOR
FOR ACCEPTING PEOPLE TO THE
UNIVERSITIES ARE HEAVILY SKEWED
TOWARD --
HIGH INCOME FAMILIES SO A TH
PROBABLY A THIRD OR MORE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ATTEND A STE THE
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLAR HARVARD OR
STANFORD ARE PAYING FULL COST
WITHOUT EVEN BOTHERING TO APPLY
FOR FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE THEY
HAVE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF MONEY --
AND AND SO THAT SO YOU KNOW --
PELL GRANT RECIPIENTS AT A
HARVARD MAYBE TWELVE OR SO AT
STANFORD --
AND 30% PLUS AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
CAMPUSES AND EVEN HIGHER THAN
THAT AT AT CSU AND SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT THE
COUNTER ARGUMENT I SUPPOSE IS
THAT THE AND I'VE.
SEEN THE BOOKS WRITTEN RIGHT
[inaudible]
THAT.
CALIFORNIA OR THE THE WHOLE
COUNTRY COULD.
OFFER FREE.
COLLEGE THAT IT HAS THE MEANS
BUT THAT WOULD --
ENTAILED SUB TYPE OF VERY AS WE
SAID -- HIGH
LEVELS OF OF SUPPORT IT WOULD BE
A HIGH LEVEL OF INVESTMENT TO
ANY OF THE PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
TO PROVIDE.
ALL OF THE TUITION AND FEES
THAT'S REQUIRED WHAT'S NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR AS LIVING EXPENSES
WHICH IS OFTEN TIMES MORE THAN.
A TUITION AT YOU SEE SO OFTEN
TWELVE TO FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS LET ME DEPENDS ON WHERE
YOU LIVE IN THE STATE BUT THAT
IS WHAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM TODAY I
THINK A PUBLIC COMMENT FROM THE
STUDENTS THAT'S WERE VERY
GENEROUS FINANCIAL AID --
STATE BUT THE COST OF LIVING
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING IS SO
EXPENSIVE HERE THAT THEY'RE
HAVING TO WORK TWO TO THREE JOBS
AND IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH AND AS
EVIDENCED BY REALLY THE TH.
THE COMPLETION OF DEGREE
COMPLETION YOU'RE SEEING THE
EFFECTS OF THAT IN ADDITION TO
OTHER STUDENTS SUPPORT THAT ARE
NECESSARY REQUIRED BUT NO THAT'S
ABSOLUTE TRUE YOU COULD PROVIDE.
ALL THE HIGHER ED INSTITUTIONS
WITH ENOUGH TUITION TO COVER
STUDENTS THAT NEED IT YOU WOULD
STILL NEED THE COVER LIVING
EXPENSES FOR THE ASTUTE.
ADMIT THINK THERE ARE TWO ISSUES
THAT ARE INTERTWINED AND IT
MIGHT HELP TO TAKE THEM
INDIVIDUALLY SO ONE IS JUST HOW
MUCH MONEY TO PUT IN THE SYSTEM.
AND I THINK AT THIS POINT THE
WAY THAT THE NATION IS WORKING
WHETHER AT STANFORD OR
CALIFORNIA.
THERE HAS BEEN AN ARRANGEMENT
THAT THOSE WHO PAY WILL PAY AND
NOT THOSE WHO CAN'T THE STATE
WILL MAKE IT WHETHER AT STANFORD
ARE THE STATE WERE TRYING TO
COVER.
AID FOR FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS WHO WENT OTHERWISE BE
ABLE TO ATTEND SO THAT'S A BASIC
TRADEOFF WE CAN CHARGE HIGHER
INCOME FOLKS LESS BUT IT WILL
MEAN EFFECTIVELY DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR LESS THAT GOES TO
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
WHETHER IT WOULD BE FOR THEIR
LIVING COSTS THEIR TUITION COSTS
TO GET.
THEM IN THE DOOR TO KEEP THEM
THEIR FOURTH YEAR IT'S IN A JUST
ON A MEDIA TRADE OFF AND THAT
NOTS YOUR CONSIDERATION DO YOU
WANT TO ACTION VERY LOW SO THAT
YOU HELP ALL STUDENTS OF EVERY
INCOME LEVEL OR DO YOU WANT TO
TARGET.
THAT'S THE BIG DECISION YOU FACE
EVERY YEAR.
THE SECOND ISSUE THOUGH THAT I
THINK IS GETTING WRAPPED UP INTO
THE CONVERSATION IS JUST WHAT
DOES THAT NEED TO BE THIS
COMPLICATED.
IF IN REALITY IT'S FREE FOR HALF
OF THE STUDENTS TO GO TO COLLEGE
WHY ISN'T THE MESSAGE BEING
CONVEYED TO THEM SO YOU LOOK AT
THE DATA AND REGARDLESS OF THE
SEGMENT.
IT IS NOTE IN.
VIRTUALLY NO CHARGE FOR MANY
STUDENTS AT ALL OF THE SEGMENTS
WHEN YOU SEE SOME OF THAT NOT
PRICES THAT CAN BE COVERED BY
WORKING TWENTY HOURS A WEEK
DURING THE ACADEMIC YEAR SO NO
KNOWN AS REQUIRED IN EVERY OTHER
COST DISCOVERED.
FOOD HOUSING TUITION IT'S ALL
COVERED I THINK WHAT WE'VE EACH
BEEN TRYING TO SAY AND DIFFERENT
WORDS IS THAT THIS CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM DOES NOT NEED TO BE THIS
COMPLICATED.
SO THAT THAT MESSAGE ISN'T
GETTING RECEIVED IF THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING ROOM REALITY
WHY DON'T WE MAKE IT CLEAR TO
STUDENTS THAT THAT IS INDEED THE
WAY CALIFORNIA WORKS. TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN WOULD REQUIRE AN
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW A STUDENT HAS
TO KNOW THAT THEY CAN QUALIFY
FOR TUITION ASSISTANCE THROUGH
THAT PROGRAM DEPENDING ON IF
THEY KNOW THEIR GPA THEIR FAMILY
INCOME THEIR ASSETS THEIR AGE
AND HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN OUT OF
COLLEGE.
AND THEN THEY MIGHT KNOW THAT UC
AND CSU PROVIDES THEM SOME OTHER
ARRANGEMENT OR IF THEY SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS YES YOU WILL
BACK PHILIP FOR THEM.
AND IT'S JUST GETS OVERWHELMING
WE HAVE A HARD TIME FIGURING IT
OUT AS OUR JOB TO DO IT STUDENTS
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE IN SOME INSTANCES --
BUT THAT WOULD REQUIRE LET'S
HAVE ONE PROGRAM CALL THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM THAT'S NOT HAVE
SIX DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND LET'S
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT HE THERE WILL
BE AN EXPECTATION YOU MIGHT HAVE
TO WORK MAYBE TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK BUT EVERYTHING ELSE IS
COVERED.
BUT THEN MAYBE WE NEED SIMPLER
RULES LIKE HEY IF YOUR FAMILY
INCOME IS LESS THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WILL COVER IT
BECAUSE MAYBE THEY DON'T GET THE
FACT THAT RULES AND THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION --
BUT AGAIN THAT'S THAT'S SORT OF
SEPARATE ISSUE ABOUT HOW WE
CONVEY WHAT THE STATE PROVIDES
[inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
THAT THE COUPLE WHO ARE
MENTIONED THAT'S CHANGED LOTS
SINCE --
NINETEEN SIXTY IS BEST SUITED
POPULATION IN THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR STUDENT POPULATION --
AND AND YOU KNOW WHERE STUDENTS
ARE COMING INTO THE SYSTEM AS
WELL -- AT
YEAH I WILL POINT THEIR LIFE IS
LIFELONG LEARNING BECOMES WHEN
NECESSARY AND TECHNOLOGY IS
CHANGING --
YOU KNOW OUR ECONOMY AND AND THE
ABILITY IF YOU WANT TO KEEP
THEIR JOBS --
HOW DOES OUR FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM --
THERE HOW SHOULD OUR FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM BE MODERNIZE TO
BETTER MEET YOU KNOW THE NEEDS
OF FOLKS.
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS LET'S
SAY -- AND
AND THEY ARE OR DOES THE CURRENT
SYSTEM.
INHIBIT THEIR ABILITY TO COME
BACK TO COLLEGE.
THERE ARE --
QUITE A FEW RULES --
IF YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE A STUDENT
EVEN --
ENTITLEMENTS CHEN COMING OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND YOU HAVE AT
LEAST A TWO POINT NO YOU'RE IN
PRETTY GOOD.
SHAPE -- IF
YOU HAVE A THREE POINT OWN
MAKING MORE MONEY OR EVEN BETTER
SHAPE.
BUT PERSON THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT YOU KNOW BEYOND.
TWENTY EIGHT AND YOU OF BEEN OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR TOO LONG YOU GET
ON THAT COMPETITIVE LIST WHICH
IS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS STRONG.
AND I ONLY HAVE --
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AWARDS THAT THAT AWARD
IS WORTH SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO FOR
A FULL TIME STUDENT FOR THE YEAR
NOW IT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH FOR
US A STUDENT THAT GENERALLY HAVE
THE FAMILY --
AND SO --
YOU WOULDN'T REALLY NEED TO NOT
ONLY SUPPORT MORE OF THE
STUDENTS BUT ALSO NEED TO
SUPPORT.
MORE OF THAT SORT OF AID TO
THOSE STUDENTS AND MAYBE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THOSE
SINCE THAT MAY NOT BE IN THE
FORM OF LIVING EXPENSES BUT
MAYBE OTHER TYPES OF SUPPORT
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM. TO TO BE
ABLE -- TO
GET THROUGH YOU KNOW FASTER SO
--
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THEY'RE IN
OUR CAL GRANT SYSTEM THERE ARE.
DEFINITE AGE YOU KNOW OUR
LIMITATIONS TRANSFER
ENTITLEMENTS TINT BICU CAN'T
COPY OF BE IT YOU CAN'T EVEN IF
IT IS A MOTIVATED STUDENTS HAS
BEEN IN THE SYSTEM PUBLIC TWO TO
FOUR YEARS TRYING TO TRANSFER.
IF YOU'RE BEYOND TWENTY EIGHT
LINK YOU MADE OTHER CHOICES
EARLIER ON YOU DON'T GET THAT
TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT.
SO YOU'RE OUT THOSE SORT OF
WOMEN THE FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY
WHATEVER THEY MIGHT HAVE FOR YOU
AT THE TIME AND IF YOU'VE
EXHAUSTED YOUR EIGHT THEN. TOO
BAD MEAN ALSO SO THERE ARE
DEFINITELY THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
FOR STUDENTS I MENTIONED EARLIER
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS.
KNOW THERE'S A WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHT THOUSAND VOTES.
IT I THINK SIXTY THOUSAND AWARDS
AND I'M NOT REMEMBERING THAT
CORRECTLY TWO THOUSAND WORDS GO
ON USED.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE --
WHETHER THEY'RE ON A PARTICULAR
PATHWAY AND THEY NEED TO PROVIDE
US WHETHER NOT THEY ARE ON A
PATHWAY IN THE DATE WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT THE DATA SYSTEM AND
THE DISPARATE DATA SYSTEM THAT
ALL OUR SYSTEMS DON'T CONNECT
THEM TALK TO EACH OTHER.
AND SO THERE'S NO WAY OF ME
REALIZING OR UNDERSTANDING
WHETHER OR NOT EX STUDENT THAT I
HAVE IN MY FINANCIALLY SYSTEM IS
ACTUALLY ON TRACK FOR A
PARTICULAR --
YOU KNOW PATHWAY THAT WOULD GIVE
THEM THIS THIS AWARD INSTEAD WE
HAVE TO SET A SUPPLEMENTAL
APPLICATION YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL UP
IT DOESN'T REALLY GET RETURN.
SO THERE ARE THINGS AND
CURRENTLY IN THE SYSTEM MAKE IT
HARDER FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE
THERE IS AWARDS FOR NOT TO TAKE
THE WORDS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
DO ONE MORE THING OR THEY HAVE
TO KNOW TO DO ONE MORE THING
YEAH.
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT
I THINK THAT WE BUT IT'S REALLY
SHARING INFORMATION NO.
ONE INSTITUTION SHOULD OWN A
STUDENTS INFORMATION ESPECIALLY
WITH REGARDS TO A STATE TO HIM
--
AGENCY BEING ABLE SO THAT WE ALL
SERVE THE STUDENT RIGHT.
THAT'S COMPANY AND A LOT OF
PRIOR DUH HEARINGS WE'VE HAD
THEN THE NEED FOR DATA SHARING
AND A DATA SYSTEM.
BUT YET SO I I'M GLAD LUPITA
MENTIONED THE AT THAT CAL GRANT
SEE I'M NOT SURE WHAT I'M WHAT
GETS THE AWARD FOR THE STRANGEST
UP PROVISION OF OF LAW BUT
CERTAINLY SOME OF THE THINGS
AROUND CAL GRANT SEE.
I SEEM AN THAT TERRITORY WHERE I
I THINK IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY
HE BASICALLY CANNOT GET AN AWARD
FOR A PROGRAM THAT GOES ANYWHERE
AT IN OTHER WORDS IT HAS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT AND THEY ARE IN
IS NOT TRANSFERABLE ONTO
ANYTHING ELSE.
AND WE HAVE CHANGED OUR THINKING
ABOUT THE WAY THE WAY WE SHOULD
THE PEOPLE.
IT AND I THINK THAT MUST COME
FROM A TIME WHEN YOU WERE
TRAINED FOR A JOB YOU GOT THAT
JOB AND THEN YOU ROSE IN THAT
JOB AND AND THAT COULD BE YOUR
LIFELONG CAREER AND NOW.
NOW YOU NEED ONGOING TRAINING
AND IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO
HAVE THAT KIND OF A OF A OF A
LIMITATION --
AND THAT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY
ALLOWING STUDENTS TO ENTER WHAT
WHATEVER PROGRAM.
APPEALS TO THEM THAT'S THE WAY
TO GET THEM.
IN THE TO GO TO COLLEGE IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND YOU CAN DO THAT
YOU YOU WITH CHANGING THE CAL
GRANT SO THAT IT IS STILL
DOESN'T HAVE ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT RESTRICTIONS BASED ON
A TIME OUT OF SCHOOL --
AT A HIGHLY SPECIFIC A GPA
REQUIREMENTS --
ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR ANYBODY
TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER THEY WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE AND IN MOST CASES
THE TRUTH NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS IF THEY FIGURED OUT THE
ANSWER IS.
YOU'RE NOT EIGIBLE --
SO THAT'S WHY THAT THE THE
EMPHASIS ON INCREASES IN
PARTICULAR. FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SERVING UP COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IT ALSO BRINGS
UP THE POINT OF ADVISING AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE RESOURCES MORE
GENERALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
VERY VERY STRETCHED IN THEIR
STAFFING --
OUTSIDE FOR FOR SUPPORT SUPPORT
SERVICES INCLUDING FINANCIAL AID
ADVISING AND EVEN THOUGH SOME
STUDENTS UP MAY WELL THERE MIGHT
BE.
A TO THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THEM AYE GETTING SOMEBODY TO
HELP WHO CAN WHO CAN HELP GUIDE
THEM THROUGH THAT --
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAUSE A THEY THE
COMMUNICATIVE ONE RUN ON A
SHOESTRING AND THEY DO A VERY
GOOD JOB --
BUT THAT KIND OF STUDENT SUPPORT
THE NUMBER THAT THAT THE
STUDENT.
THE ADVISER RATIO IS IS SUCH
THAT.
IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT TO DO THE
KIND OF OUTREACH THAT WOULD
REALLY HELP NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS AND YEAH AND AND YOU
KNOW THAT THEIR LITTLE FROM
MONEY COULD HAVE A BIG OUR ALLY
IN TERMS OF STUDENTS GETTING
THROUGH FASTER AND AND BEING
ABLE TO MOVE ON I'M YOU ALL.
MENTIONED THE INADEQUACIES SOME
INADEQUACIES AROUND THE THE
CURRENT CAL GRANT STRUCTURE --
AND ENCOURAGED --
REFORM OF THAT STRUCTURE
TYPICALLY WHAT I'VE SEEN AND I
HAVE BEEN HERE THAT LONG --
ANYTIME YOU REFORM SOMETHING
OTHERS WINNERS AND LOSERS IN THE
LOSERS DURING A GOOD JOB OF
KILLING THE REFORM BEFORE YOU
CAN ACCOMPLISH IT.
IS THERE FROM WHAT YOU'VE SEEN
OF OF DIFFERENT MODELS FOR
REFORMING THE CAL GRANT SYSTEM
IS THEIR WAY TO DO THIS WHERE
EVERYONE WINS.
OR WILL WILL WILL THERE
INEVITABLY BE BE SOME LOSERS
THAT ARE GONNA --
YOU KNOW KIND OF TRY TO OPPOSE
[inaudible]
THOSE EFFORTS.
I THINK THAT WE WE WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH THE FIVE
SEGMENTS TRYING TO GET SOME IN A
CONSENSUS AROUND AT LEAST THAT
CONSOLIDATION AND IN GENERAL
THERE'S A SUPPORT FOR
CONSOLIDATION.
BUT IT.
IN THE END THE COMMITTEE CALLED
SEGMENT DOESN'T REALLY WENT OUT
THERE THREE STACKED ME BUT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY IN THEIR FAVOR.
UNLESS THE BE ACCESS AWARD IS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY TO
ASSIST THEIR STUDENTS SO.
ALL BOATS HAVE TO RISE AND WE
ALL KNOW THAT WE HAVE ALL SEEN
IN K. TWELVE AND COALITION WHEN
THEY COME AND LOBBY ALL VOTES
HAVE TO RISE IN ORDER FOR
EVERYONE TO BE ON BOARD.
WE'VE COSTED OUT THE
CONSOLIDATION THAT WE HAVE THE
CONSOLIDATION AND STREAMLINED TO
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WE WERE TO INCREASE THE
ACCESS AWARD TO THE LITTLE NEXT
LEVEL UP IS ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS --
AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
LOT OF MONEY BUT THIS IS.
WHAT YOU'RE NOT GETTING YOUR ROI
WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING IN THE
CURRENT TWO BILLION DOLLARS AND
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE STUDENT
SUCCESS THAT YOU WANT OUT OF IT
SO THERE IS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
WHAT WHAT THE STATE WANTS AND
WHAT THE STATE'S GETTING IT WITH
REGARDS TO THEIR RETURN ON?
INVESTMENT SO I DO THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE AN INVESTMENT --
AND WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT SORT
OF HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE IT SO
THAT THAT THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SEGMENT DOES FEEL THAT THEY'RE A
PART OF A DEAL THE WINNERS.
ABSOLUTELY --
I'VE MUCH MORE QUESTIONS BUT OWN
RESPECTIVE ONCE TIMES THE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP --
AND THEN FOR THE FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU UP PARTICIPATING TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT.
I'M GONNA FIND MY SCRIPT BUT I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE MOVING ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THERE IT IS --
SO NOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAVE A LOT OF
THIRTY FIVE MINUTES [inaudible]
ISSUE.
AND HAVE A LIST OF FOLKS WHO
LIKE TO SPEAK --
SO AND WE HAVE A LIKE THE LIST
OF FOLKS WHO WANT TO SPEAK SO
FOLKS CAN LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS
TO ONE TO TWO MINUTES AT MOST
THAT WOULD BE GREAT --
AND PLEASE ALSO FOR FREE TO
REACH OUT TO MY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR ALAN GREEN WHO'S TO MY
LEFT --
WHO'S THE POINT PERSON FOR THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON MY TEAM AND
IF YOU SEND ALLEN AN EMAIL WITH
YOUR EMAIL ADDRESS YOU CAN ADD
YOU TO THE LIST SO YOU'RE KEPT
IN THE LOOP AS WE PROGRESS.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HEAR FROM
YOU IN DISCUSS THE WORK OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE WITH WITH ANY
INDIVIDUAL OR INDIVIDUAL
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS QUESTIONS
US WHY TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK --
OLIVER STAM'S --
BUT ESPECIALLY ALLEN AND I
LEGISLATIVE FELT WAS WITH SMITH
--
WHO I DID ALL THE WORK TO A PUT
TODAY'S HEARING TOGETHER ON THAT
HAD ALL THE INTERACTIONS WITH
THE PANELISTS AND?
DIED DID THEIR BEST TO TRY TO
MAKE ME SOUND SMART AS HARD AS
THAT IS --
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THE ALL THESE [inaudible]
PUBLIC BECAUSE ANY MIKE CLOCK --
CLUNKY --
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF THIS
FIRST OF THE PACIFIC.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE HIS CLOCKING YOU'RE
ON THE SECOND TRY THAT'S NOT BAD
--
YEAH I KNOW WE KNOW THAT THE ARE
THE CHALLENGE THE LEGISLATURE
FACES AND HARM.
DECISIONS WITH ALL SECTORS OF
BUDGET CUTS HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND THAT BEING SAID WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THE CAN'T CAL GRANT
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN
THE PAST BECAUSE OUR STUDENTS AS
WELL AS THOSE FROM. EIGHTY PLUS
OTHER PRIVATE NON PROFITS RELY
AND THE GRANTS.
LIMON ANECDOTAL EXAMPLE WE HAVE
A COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT PROGRAM
AT PACIFIC THAT FOR THE PAST
FORTY NINE YEARS IS PROVIDING A
GATEWAY FOR FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
FROM STOCKTON --
THEIR FORTY FIVE PEOPLE EACH
YEAR IN THAT AND VIRTUALLY ALL
OF THEM RELY AND CAL GRANTS --
STATISTIC ONLY 18% OF ADULTS IN
STOCKTON HAVE COLLEGE DEGREES
WERE WORKING HARD TO TRY TO FIX
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO A LOT ON
OUR END.
WE'RE TEAMING UP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN DIFFERENT
WAYS AND WERE FULL SUPPORTERS OF
SUSAN EGGMAN SITS EFFORTS TO DO
A LOT [inaudible] FOR A CAL CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY IN STOCKTON THE
CITY OF THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AS A SELECT COMMITTEE CRAP SO
LONG TERM VISION FOR HIGHER ED.
IN THE STATE WE URGE THE MEMBERS
TO CONSIDER THE CONTINUING AN
ESCALATING FINANCIAL NEEDS OF
STUDENTS ON EIGHTY TWO DIFFERENT
PRIVATE NONPROFIT CARE CAMPUSES
THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER COCKY.
NEXT UP WE HAVE THOMAS VIEW IT
AS YOU SEE YOU FOLLOWED BY.
JUDITH GRAY GET I BELIEVE AT
NOTRE DAME DE NAMUR UNIVERSITY.
AND AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S TOM WHO I'M
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
ARE.
USE THE ORGANIZATION OF TWO
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT SOME
OF THEM ARE HERE TODAY INCLUDING
--
UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC WHO
JUST CAME UP.
OF FIRST A THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THESE HEARINGS THAT THROUGHOUT
THIS YEAR OF AND INVOLVING THE
INDEPENDENT HIGHER EDUCATION
SECTOR --
THE INDEPENDENT HIGHER EDUCATION
SECTOR HAS BEEN A PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN SINCE ITS CREATION
BACK IN --
NINETEEN SIXTY IN HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE AND CREATING AND
YOU'RE CREATING A CAPACITY FOR A
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN REGARDS TO US THE FINANCIAL
AID FOR EACH DOLLAR THAT EACH OF
OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE --
IN --
THEY'RE COVERING AWARD OUR
INSTITUTIONS PROVIDE TWO DOLLARS
SO DOUBLE --
I THINK THIS SHOWS THE
COMMITMENT.
THAT OUR INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO
STUDENT ACCESS AND SUCCESS AND
ESPECIALLY --
FOR THOSE FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES --
AND FROM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
--
WE DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORTS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO STABILIZE
THE CAL TO WORK FOR STUDENTS OF
THIS YEAR --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
CAL GRANT FOR THE INDEPENDENT
SECTOR.
IS THE ONLY SOURCE OF STATE AID
THAT OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE.
US WAS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
STUDENTS THAT THE AWARD IS
STABLE AND PROPERLY FUNDED A
HOWEVER THAT WHAT HAS NOT SEEN
AN INCREASE --
US FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS NOW.
AND GONNA CONSIDERING --
CUTS AND ALSO IN FOR SINCE THEN
SCRUTINY OF THE AWARD HAS LOST
SOMETHING OF AROUND 35% OF ITS
VALUE -- IT.
AND SO AS YOU BEGIN LOOKING AT
HOW THE STATE CAN --
INCREASE ITS INVESTMENT IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND IT REALLY
IS AN INVESTMENT IN THE TRUEST
SENSE OF THE WORD --
AND HOW STATE FINANCIALLY A
COMPLAINTS OF THAT YOU KNOW WE
ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT INCREASING
THE AWARD OVER TIME --
FOR OUR STUDENTS THROUGH A
FORMULA --
THAT TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION-THE AWARD AMOUNT
OF THE UC'S AND
OF THIS YES USE.
RATHER THEN A LINE ITEM IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE
JUDITH CRAIG FOLLOWED BY JAKE
BERMAN BERMAN ARE.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH I YEAH.
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE PROJECT
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN ON IS MASSIVE
AND IT'S REALLY AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF WORK FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING IT ON JUST GREAT NOTRE
DAME CHEN IN YOUR UNIVERSITY.
OF A RESPECTED DOCTOR WEBBER'S
QUESTIONS AND A HOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA'S QUESTIONS --
BUT DOCTOR ROBERTS QUESTION
DOESN'T REALLY FIT FOR THE
PRIVATE [inaudible]
UP BECAUSE STATE AID GRANTED TO
THE STUDENT IS THE ONLY KIND OF
AID THAT A STUDENT PRIVATE WOULD
GET AND YOU JUST HEARD FROM TOM
THAT THAT IT'S A REALLY IT'S
ESSENTIAL FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA STUDENT SO --
IT DOESN'T REALLY FIT.
A IN THE SAME WAY SO WHILE I
WANT US I'M A MEMBER OF THE
STUDENT A COMMISSION WANT US TO
SIMPLIFY AND STREAMLINE --
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO THINK BOTH
PRIVATE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY --
NONE AND OF POINT IT DIDN'T
REALLY COMMIT TO STRONGLY IN THE
TESTIMONY OF THE CAL GRANT
ACTUALLY STARTED TO HELP
STUDENTS IN THE PRIVATES BE ABLE
TO ACCESS IN HELP.
STATE FILL CAPACITY ISSUES THAT
REMAIN TO THIS DAY FOR PROVISION
OF HIGHER ED IN AND PRIVATE
SECTORS REALLY STILL HAS NOT
ONLY THE CAPACITY OPPORTUNITY
BUT THE CHOICE OPPORTUNITY.
A SMALL PRIVATE IS THE RIGHT
CHOICE FOR SOME STUDENTS AND
WHEN WE WANT TO MAINTAIN THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RENDON IS
QUESTION --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CLOUT
TALKED ABOUT THEM.
WE HAVE A PRESTIGE SYSTEM IN THE
STATE.
IN TERMS OF ENROLLMENT IN AID --
WE HAVE THAT KIND OF PECKING
ORDER AMONG THE PRIVATES AS
WELL.
AND THAT'S WHERE AID BECOMES
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE AN
INSTITUTION LIKE MINE.
WE HAVE WE ENROLL AS MANY.
LOW INCOME FIRST GENERATION --
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AS
MANY OF THE AC. S. USED DO AND
YET -- WE
DON'T HAVE THE KIND RESOURCES
THAT SOME OF THE PRESTIGE AND
STE IT'S WHAT'S THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
I JAKE BERMAN ARE FOLLOWED BY
LORE STUD SABO LUBITZ
[inaudible] TWO BITS
[inaudible]
NOT SURE.
WE'LL GET.
SO CLEAN THAT UP.
YEAH SO A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BERMAN AND I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOU AND ELLEN AND
ELIZABETH FOR BRINGING TOGETHER
SUCH THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS ON
ISSUE SO CRITICAL TO CALIFORNIA
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR FUTURE --
JUST LAST WEEK THE CAMPAIGN
RELEASED ARE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT CARD ON HIGHER EDUCATION
IN WHICH WE ASSESS CALIFORNIA
AND HOW IT'S DOING THAT FUNDING
OUR UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES TO
MEET STUDENT DEMAND.
AS WELL AS HOW AFFORDABLE THOSE
OPTIONS ARE PARTICULARLY FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO PACE THE GAP ONE
POINT SIX MILLION COLLEGE
GRADUATES BY TWENTY THIRTY AND
THE GOOD NEWS HERE IS THAT IF WE
CAN CLOSE THAT GAP WE WANT YOUR
CALIFORNIA BOTH RETAINS ITS
STANDING AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WHILE ALSO CLOSING THE
PERSISTENT RACIAL A MORE GOOD
NEWS THE LEGISLATURE'S RECENT
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND YOU SEE
CAPACITY IN PARTICULAR ARE
WORKING PARTICULARLY FOR LATIN
NEXT AND BLACK STUDENTS.
AFTER ADDING SEATS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN OVERALL ADMISSIONS
INCREASED BY 5% BUT BY 9% FOR
LATIN NEXT AND BLACK STUDENTS
APPLYING TO THE YOU SEE.
SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE THESE
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND CAPACITY
UNTIL AT LEAST 40% OF OUR
QUALIFIED HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
CAN ENROLL DIRECTLY INTO THE YOU
SEE OR THE CSU.
ON FINANCIAL AID CALIFORNIA
HASN'T DONE SO WELL AT
MAINTAINING THE CAL GRANTS
PURCHASING POWER AT THOSE NON
TUITION COSTS WERE CAUGHT HER
TIME ON THE LAST PANEL CONTINUE
TO RISE.
THE DESPITE A MODEST INCREASES
TO THE MAXIMUM AWARD UNMET NEED
AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR FINANCIAL
AID HAS INCREASED BY MORE THAN
50% AT THE COLLEGES AND IT'S
MORE THAN DOUBLED AT THE CSU AND
YOU SEE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE A WE STILL HAVE FAR TOO FEW
GRANTS FOR COMMUNITY. FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
PAY NO TUITION AND BUDGET CENTER
REPORTED YESTERDAY THAT LAST
YEAR THE PERCENT OF ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS AWARDED A COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT.
WAS LOWER THAN THE ADMISSION
RATE AT UC BERKELEY.
SOMETHING IS BROKEN WITH
FINANCIAL AID WHEN IT'S HARDER
FOR STUDENTS TO AND COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT MINUTE SPOT AT TALLIL
--
SO I WE WOULD RECOMMEND CONCERT
BOTH EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF
THOSE COMPETITIVE AWARDS BUT
LONG TERM TOWARD THAT VISION OF
A CONSOLIDATED SIMPLIFIED GRANT
PROGRAM THAT IS BASED.
ON THAT THE NEED BASED PROGRAMS
THAT WITH THAT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NEXT IS LAURA.
SABO COUP IT'S FROM TI GUESS
YEAH.
GREAT JOB I CAN BARELY SAY AT
THAT.
AND YET FLORA SUB ACUTE IT'S
FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS ME REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
TODAY IN PARTICULAR.
ARE THE FOCUS BY PRISONERS ON
THE CRITICAL NEED TO COVER AYE
CRITICAL NINE TUITION COSTS FOR
NEEDY STUDENTS.
CLEARLY THE STATUS QUO IS NOT
SUFFICIENT AND IT'S IMPERATIVE
TO STRENGTHEN STATE NEED BASED
AID BOTH BY INCREASING THE VALUE
OF THE CAL GRANT THE ACCESS
AWARD THAT HELPS COVER.
AYE NEEDY STUDENTS NON TUITION
COSTS AS WELL AS INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF AVAILABLE COMPETITIVE
AWARD SO THAT MORE OF THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
OF ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS MANY OF
WHOM.
RECEIVE AN AWARD THAT HELPS THEM
GET TO AND SUCCESSFULLY THROUGH
COLLEGE AND I KNOW THAT BOTH OF
THESE ARE SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIANS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY ARE DIVERSE
COALITION OF TWO DOZEN
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO JUST WANT TO QUICKLY
NOTE THAT BOTH OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD HELP
MITIGATE NET PRICE WHICH THE
DATA SHOW PLACE THE GREATEST
BURDENS ON OUR LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS WE LOOK AT THE SHARE OF
THEIR TOTAL INCOME THAT HAS TO
GO TO ON COLLEGE COSTS AFTER.
ON THE E. THAT THEY RECEIVE --
FROM THE WHAT WE ARE ALSO HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE ON
OTHER WAYS TO BUILD TOWARD
AFFORDABILITY.
AYE AFFORDABLE HIGHER EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA AND LOOK FORWARD
TO FUTURE OPPORTUNITIES TO
DISCUSS AND COLLABORATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU LAUREN
--
AND NEXT THAT WE ARE DAVID
POULTER FOLLOWED BY KIERAN
FLAHERTY.
I THINK IT'S EVER MEN AND STAFF
--
DURING THE FIRST HEARING I
COMMENT OF THE SILICON VALLEY
SILICON VALLEY'S INNOVATION
ECONOMY IS FUELED BY STEM TALENT
BUT THAT ARE --
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
WE'RE PRODUCING STEM GRADUATES
AT A LOWER RATE THAN OTHER
INNOVATION HUBS LIKE AUSTIN AND
BOSTON.
AND THAT IT WAS AS A RESULT MANY
OF OUR COMPANIES ARE TURNING TO
OUT OF STATE TALENT TO COMPETE
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN ONLY
20% OF STEM WORKERS.
IN SILICON VALLEY WERE BORN IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ONLY 18% --
PARTIALLY BECAUSE THIS IS YOUR
LAST HEARING I WANTED TO RELATE
TO THIS COMMITTEE SOME GOOD
NEWS.
OUR RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT ARE
REGION'S GROWTH IN STEM DEGREES
CONFERRED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN THE LAST
YEAR STUDIED.
EXCEEDED GROWTH AND OTHER
COMPARABLE REGIONS SO 16% GROWTH
IN STEM DEGREES CONFERRED FROM
BAY AREA COLLEGES FOR INSTANCE
VERSUS 10% IN AUSTIN AND BOSTON.
ABOUT RAMPING UP THIS GROWTH
RATES EVEN FURTHER BY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
THROUGH FUNDING LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE.
A IS CRITICAL NOT ONLY TO OUR
INDUSTRIES BUT TO ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
HAVE A PLACE IN OUR INNOVATION
ECONOMY.
AGAIN I WANT TO ECHO EVERYONE
ELSE'S WORDS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND FOR YOUR OPEN FRAMING
OF THIS WHOLE PROJECT --
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SUMMARY
[inaudible]
THANKS DAVID.
NEXT UP WE HAVE KIERAN FLAHERTY
FOLLOWED BY VALERIE JOHNSON.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN KIERAN
FLAHERTY DIRECTOR OF STATE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
I WANT TO START BY JUST THINKING
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES --
SOME OF OUR MOST ARDENT
ADVOCATES FOR YOU SEE HAVE BEEN
HERE AS PART OF THIS --
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WE THINK WE HAVE MUCH BETTER
OUTCOMES THIS YEAR AND THINGS
HAVE REALLY --
STARTED TO TURN AROUND --
AS YOU ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR SETTING UP A THOUGHTFUL AND
DELIBERATE IF PROCESS HAVING A
SERIES OF OF FIVE HEARINGS TO
ESTABLISH A BASELINE OF
UNDERSTANDING.
IT NEEDS TO BE DONE EVERY
SEVERAL YEARS --
THINGS ARE CHANGING AND EVOLVING
WITH RESPECT TO FUNDING SOURCES
AND WITH RESPECT TO OUR FACULTY
STAFF STUDENTS AND AND THE WORK
FORCE NEED SO I THINK IT MAKES.
GOOD SENSE FOR US TO COME BACK
AND BE VISIT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
I IT DOES GIVE ME HOPE THERE IS
A NATIONAL NARRATIVE OUT THERE
THAT DOUBTS THE VALUE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AND WHAT IT CAN DO FOR A STATE
OR WHAT IT CAN DO FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND HEARING
CALIFORNIA OUR ELECTED
LEADERSHIP I RUN COUNTER TO THAT
NARRATIVE.
THEY DON'T DOUBT ABOUT THE VALUE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
REALLY BUILD ON WE HAVE A
BEDROCK PRINCIPLE AT YOU SEE.
AND THAT IS THAT QUALITY IS
TANTAMOUNT WITH ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY.
WE DO THINK THAT WE CAN EVOLVE
AND CHANGE AND IMPROVE THERE'S
ALWAYS ROOM FOR THAT THAT IS
PART OF QUALITY --
WE ALSO THINK THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AT THE SAME TIME TO
GROW RESEARCH AND PUBLIC SERVICE
AS PART OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
MISSION.
AND AND WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
THAT'S BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED IN THE
ENGAGEMENT THAT YOU.
AND YOUR STAFF HAVE HAD WITH THE
UNIVERSE --
MY OFFICE AND THEN OTHER
I'M YOU KNOW HERE AT THIS FINAL
HEARING FOR NOW --
WE JUST WANT TO YOU I PLEDGE OUR
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT WITH YOU --
WITH THE OTHER PUBLIC SEGMENTS
AND THE INDEPENDENCE AND I
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER --
TO SEE SEE WHAT MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE THANK YOU THANK YOU
KAREN.
UNLESS WE HAVE VALERIE JOHNSON
FOLLOWED BY A HUNTER LAMELLAE
[inaudible]
AND HELLO MY NAME IS VALERIE
JOHNSON AND I'M A STUDENT AT
CRAFTED HILLS COLLEGE I ALSO
SERVE AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
SYSTEM AFFAIRS FOR THE STUDENT
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND I WANTED TO THANK YOU CHAIR
BERMAN AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS.
AND THE SYSTEM UNDER ADVISEMENT
WHEN YOU IMPLEMENT A MASTER PLAN
THAT WORKS ACROSS ALL THE PUBLIC
SEGMENTS OF THANK YOU --
THE OVER TWO MILLION STUDENTS AT
THE ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE FACE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES.
A THEY HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED WHEN
ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR THE
SCHOOLS.
SO WHEN WORKING TO MODERNIZE THE
PLAN TO BETTER THE MASTER PLAN
UP PLEASECONSIDER THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE MANY
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
AND THIS MUST BE CONSIDERED.
WHEN ALLOCATING FUNDS AS IT'S
MORE EXPENSIVE TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS LIKE THEY REQUIRE --
ADDITIONALLY WE ASK THAT YOU
SIMPLIFY AND MODERNIZE THE
FINANCIAL AID PROCESS TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEIR EDUCATION
KNOWING WHAT THEY'RE WORKING
WITH -- SO
THIS WOULD MEAN PROVIDING
RETURNING AND NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS WITH ACCESS TO CALL
GRANTS AND TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT.
I'M SOCIALLY FOR STUDENTS AT A
HIGHER YOU JUST MENTIONED IT
BEFORE I'M STUDENTS IN THEIR
LATE TWENTIES AND AND PASSED
THAT HAVE A LOT OF TROUBLES
SECURING THAT.
FINANCIAL AID AND KNOWING WHAT
THEY'RE WORKING WITH GOING
FORWARD --
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD BE GREAT
TO CONNECT PATHWAYS AND SYSTEMS
BY DATA SHARING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR STUDENTS TO TAKE LESS
STEPS TO GO AHEAD AND GET THAT
FINANCIAL AID AWARD --
THE LAST UPSET THEY TAKE THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE TO MAKE IT
TO THAT FINAL FINANCIALLY
TOWARD.
ADDITIONALLY --
WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THE
BROAD COST OF ATTENDANCE THAT
DOES NOT INCLUDE TUITION AND
FEES SO MANY ASSUME THAT BECAUSE
STUDENTS ARE ATTENDING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THEY'RE LIVING AT HOME
AND BEING SUPPORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AND THIS IS NOT THE CASE --
A LOT OF THE TIME MANY HAVE
FAMILIES OF THEIR OWN AND WORK
MULTIPLE JOBS --
AND WE CANNOT ASSUME THAT THE
HOUSTON PORTED OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
SO WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER --
THAT NEEDS OF OUTSIDE TUITION
FEES.
AND A LOT OF THE STUDENTS FACE
FOOD INSECURITY THEY FACE
HOUSING INSECURITY AND LARGE
COST OF TRANSPORTATION --
SO PLEASE CONSIDER OFFERING
FINANCIAL AID ASSISTANCE AS WELL
AS CONSIDERATION WITH COST OF
LIVING IN THE SURROUNDING AREAS
MANY AREAS ARE MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN OTHERS.
AND THE STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGE JUST NEED YOU
TO PROTECT PRIORITIZE FUNDING
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND WE ASK
YOU ALWAYS KEEP STUDENT AT THE
FOREFRONT. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATIONS WHEN YOU'RE
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VALERIE.
NEXT OF WE HAVE ALL HUNTER
LAMELLAE FOLLOWED BY ME --
CAGAYAN US [inaudible]
KINDA CLOSE.
ALL PARK MAYBE SOME FANATICS
WILL HELP ON THE SHE THEM TIMES.
HELLO --
CHAMBER BERMAN MY NAME IS
TELEVANGELISM A RECENT GRADUATE
OF LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE AND
AS OF AUGUST WE SEVEN I WILL BE
S. UNIT COST ONE BEACH --
I HAD SOME COMMENTS WERE IN
EARLIER BUT AFTER SOME COMMENTS
EARLIER TODAY I WANT TO ANSWER
HOPEFULLY ONE QUESTION --
THAT BY ASSEMBLYMAN WEBER
MENTIONED --
AND SHE ASKS THE CONSPECIFIC LEE
YOU KNOW WHO ARE THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE PAYING FOR EDUCATION
AND WHAT ARE THEY ACTUALLY
PAYING --
AND YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK OF
THAT I THINK OF YOU KNOW THE
FIRST GROUP THAT COMES TO MIND
IS OUR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS.
WHO COME FROM A BACKGROUND THAT
DOES NOT PRIORITIZE A CULTURE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION?
AND DOES NOT EVEN PRIORITIZE OR
KNOW HOW TO EVEN APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE STUDENTS THAT
FOR WHATEVER REASON YOU KNOW
LIFE HAPPENS WE TALK ABOUT THE
SITUATIONS AND ARE DEEMED
INELIGIBLE FINANCIALLY WHETHER
IT'S BECAUSE OF A LOW GPA OR
SOMETHING.
BUT I NEVER UNDERSTOOD THE
MINDSET THAT SOME PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THAT IF THEY DO HAVE A TO
POINT A GP IN OUR DEEMED
INELIGIBLE.
IN SOME FORM IN THAT PROCESS
THEY COME UP WITH TONS OF MONEY
AND CAN FINANCE THEMSELVES AN
UPCOMING SEMESTERS.
YOU KNOW LEAVING THEM IN A
VORTEX WHERE THEY HAVE TO FIND
DIFFERENT WITH IT'S TO FINANCE
THEIR EDUCATION EVEN GET OUT OF
THAT.
PASSAGEWAY XIN.
IT ALSO ARE NOT TRADITIONAL
STUDENTS WHO ARE BY WHATEVER
METRICS ARE ELIGIBLE YOU KNOW
THAT THE STATE --
FINDS -- BUT
JUST YOU KNOW WHAT WHETHER IT'S
TIME OUT OF COLLEGE TIME IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND EVEN THEIR EIGHT
SPECIFICALLY ADDING THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR FOR FINANCIAL AID.
AND YOU KNOW I WENT LOOKING ON
THE FEW I CAN POLY GUARANTEE
THAT SOME PEOPLE AND SOME FORMER
WAY ARE STILL PAYING FOR THEIR
EDUCATION.
WHETHER THAT'S AND THAT
REIMBURSEMENTS OR WHETHER THAT'S
YOU KNOW LOOKING INTO A
DIFFERENT POTENTIAL OR FUTURE
DEGREE.
I'M BUT SOME FORMS ARE ON THIS
RUMOR EVEN PAYING FOR THAT AND
YOU KNOW I ALSO WONDER STUDENTS
I START SCHOOL ON AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH --
MY FIRST YOU HAD A COMMUNICABLE
IT I WAS PAYING ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS JUST FOR HOUSING
EXPENSES LOAN --
EVEN UNDERSTANDING THE CAL GRANT
BE.
JUST OVER A BROWN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED YOU KNOW DOESN'T EVEN
GET CLOSE --
TO THAT THE SIX THOUSAND I WAS
BOTH THE PAIN.
AND THEM ARE STERN ADVOCATES AND
NONPROFIT PARTNERS HAS SPENT YOU
KNOW YEARS IN MEETINGS LIKE THIS
TRYING TO CONVINCE FOLKS.
THAT EVEN NON TUITION COSTS ARE
FACTORED A STUDENT SUCCESS AND
WE HOPE IN THE UPCOMING MONTHS
IN.
YOU KNOW CONVERSATIONS LIKE
THESE THAT WE HAVE MEANINGFUL
DATA INCLUDED FROM YOU KNOW THE
SEER SERVANT THINGS LIKE THAT.
TO FINALLY CONVINCE FOLKS THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS A FACTOR AND WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD TO A STATE THAT
REALLY FUNDS STUDENTS --
AT A THRIVING ECONOMY YOU KNOW
FIFTH IN THE WORLD RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL UNDER.
THE NEXT UP WE HAVE MEDIA.
FOLLOWED BY ISAIAH OF YOU
IDEALLY CREWS.
AND MIA SUFFER BUT SURELY LASTED
PAST DECADE YOU'RE THAT FAR OUT.
AND SO GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
CHAIR BERMAN MY NAME IS MIA QUE
JANICE.
AND I AM A STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
STATE AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CAL STATES UNISYS ASIAN BUT
REPRESENTS ALL CSU STUDENTS
STATEWIDE.
WE FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE HEARINGS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE LAST YEAR.
STUDENTS LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE POLICY PROPOSALS THAT COME
FROM THIS WORK. ONE CONVERSATION
WE ARE CONCERNED TO HEAR IS THE
UNRAVELING OF FINANCIAL AID TO
ONLY FOCUS ON TUITION COSTS IN
THE CSU.
WHICH HAS ONLY ONE FOURTH OF
WHAT IT COST TO ATTEND THE CSU.
STUDENTS WHO HAVE THEIR TUITION
COVERED ARE STILL STRUGGLING
WITH THAT HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSECURITY.
AND ME MORE NOT LESS AID. ONE
POINT THAT WE'D LIKE TO MAKE IS
THE ABSOLUTE NEED FOR A MULTI
YEAR FUNDING AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY EACH YEAR THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES CREATES A
FUNDING REQUEST TO THE STATE.
AN INSTITUTION AND STAKEHOLDERS
LIKE ICE ADVOCATE FOR A FULLY
FUNDED BUDGET.
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE COME HERE AND
TELL YOU THE SAME STORY WITH
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FLAVORS.
A THRIVING CAL STATE SYSTEM AS
THE ABSOLUTE KEY TO THE SUCCESS
OF CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
THIS PROCESS IS ABSOLUTELY
EXHAUSTING AND IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY NOT WORKING.
IT DOESN'T WORK FOR THE CSU AT
DOESN'T WORK FOR THE STATE AND
IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T WORK FOR
STUDENTS.
WITHOUT A MULTI YEAR FOR THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT WE CANNOT
ACCOMPLISH ALL OF OUR SHARED
GOALS.
LIKE INCREASE GRADUATION RATES
AND LIMIT THEIR ACHIEVEMENT OR
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
WITHOUT A MULTI YEAR BUDGET
AGREEMENT WE CAN'T
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSED THE
NEAR THREE BILLION DOLLARS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG IN
THE CSU.
WITHOUT A MULTI YEAR BUDGET
AGREEMENT MORE STUDENTS WILL BE
TURNED AWAY FROM THE INSTITUTION
BECAUSE NO LONG TERM ENROLLMENT
STRATEGY CAN BE REASONABLY
ADOPTED.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
STUDENTS ARE LEFT DEFENSELESS
AGAINST UNPREDICTABLE AND
VOLATILE TUITION AND FEE
INCREASES.
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR THE
INSTITUTION THE STUDENTS ARE ALL
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CASTING SYSTEM.
WHICH IS WHY A MULTI YEAR
FUNDING AGREEMENT BETWEEN ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IS CRUCIAL TO LONG
TERM SUCCESS OF THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEDIA.
THEN EXCEPT WE HAVE EYES THE OF
YOUR BILL THE CREWS FOLLOWED BY
JONATHAN HUGHES I'M GONNA SPEAK
FAST AS WE CAN GET ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THIS. FOR DECADES THE
IDEALS THE MASTER PLAN HAS STOOD
FOR HAS PLACED CALIFORNIA'S
INSTITUTIONS AT THE TOP SORT OF
A STATE ON A HILL IF YOU WILL.
ONE IN PARTICULAR OWN FOCUS ON
IS THAT ACADEMIC PROGRESS SHOULD
BE LIMITED ONLY BY AN
INDIVIDUAL'S PROFICIENCY.
AS WELL NO EX IN ASSURING ACCESS
TO ALL REGARDLESS OF SOCIO
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND.
HOWEVER IF WE MEASURE OUR
SUCCESS BY GRADUATION RATES
STUDENTS A FULFILLMENT OF BASIC
NEEDS AND EMPLOYMENT RATES.
I'D SAY THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
BEGUN TO SLIP.
I WANT NOTHING MORE THAN FOR
CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN THE SHINING
STATE ON THE HILL.
WE NEED TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS NOW SO WE CAN REMAIN
AN EXCELLENT INSTITUTION IN THE
FUTURE YOU ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PIONEERS.
OF A GRANT INSTITUTIONAL CHANGE
A CHANGE WHICH WILL KEEP
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST GREAT BUT
SMART AGAIN.
INTELLECTUAL AGAIN SUCCESSFUL
AGAIN.
AS A STUDENT WITH A FULL LOAD A
THREE POINT SIX GPA AT ONE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER WHO ONCE HAD TO
WORK FOR JOBS WHO ONCE HAD
NEGATIVE FIVE DOLLARS IN HIS
BANK ACCOUNT.
AND WHO WAS LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY THE ANECDOTES OF
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS AT HIS
CAMPUS AND OTHER CAMPUSES I'M
FEW QUESTIONS THAT I HOPE WE CAN
ALL RESULT.
QUESTION ONE WHAT IS
AFFORDABILITY [inaudible]
QUESTION.
TWO DOES OUR DEFINITION OF
AFFORDABILITY INCLUDE FOOD
HOUSING THREE CAN BE CUT COST
SHOULD WE FOR IF WE CUT COSTS
HOW WILL THIS IMPACT THE QUALITY
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS. FIVE WHAT
CAN WE LEARN FROM OTHER STATES
AND COUNTRIES LIKE AUSTRALIA OR
NEW YORK [inaudible] SIX UP.
IN CONCLUSION IF BASIC NEEDS ARE
PROVIDED FOR THEN AS I AS WE ALL
KNOW FULL ACADEMIC POTENTIAL
NEVER BE REACHED.
LASTLY I HAVE ONE MORE THING
[inaudible]
TO DO.
I'M CONVINCED THAT IGNORANCE
WOULD BE DISMISSED ONLY IF
EDUCATION WAS OUR FIRST OFFENSE
STUDENTS WERE TENSE BECAUSE OF
THE COST OF PAYING RENTS ALL
TIME IS SPENT WORKING TO TO FOR
JOBS.
WE WERE BORN AND CURSED POR IS
THIS WHAT LIFE WAS MEANT TO BE.
NO TIME TO STUDY WERE FOREVER
STRUGGLING AT THE BOTTOM OF MASS
LOW'S HIERARCHY.
I'M NOT A POET I'M JUST A
PRUDENT STUDENT WHO BELIEVES
THAT HUMANS SHOULD RECOGNIZE
LIFE'S IMPROVEMENT.
CRITICAL THINKING IS ON THE
BRINK OF SINKING MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES CONTRIBUTED BINGE
DRINKING THE STUDENT BODY IS
DROWNING IN A SEA OF DEBT
[inaudible]
WE NEED.
A SOLUTION BEFORE BE GASPAR LAST
PRESS ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE I'M
REALLY GLAD YOU'RE FOCUSED NOW
LET'S GET A SOLUTION DOWN ON THE
BALLOT OR SOMETHING BEFORE
NOVEMBER ROLLS ALONG IN THE
VOTERS START VOTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M LOOKING FORCING YOU ON
BROADWAY.
NEXT UP WE HAVE JOHNSON HERE
JOHN OF THIS YEAR'S FOLLOWED BY
DAISY MAX IN.
WELL THAT'S HARD TO FOLLOW TIES
GRITTIER FROM SEEDS BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'M MISTER CHAIR AND
STAFF WHOEVER'S LEFT --
O. JONATHAN HUGHES ON BEHALF OF
HIS YOU SPECIFIC UNIVERSITY I
REPRESENT ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS TWELVE HUNDRED OF WHOM
I RECEIVE THE CAL GRANT AIR BE I
JUST FOR CONTEXT WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT OUR DIVERSE NEEDS OF OUR
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATIONS --
THIS PAST FALL FORTY FOUR AND A
HALF PERCENT ABOUT OF OUR
STUDENTS WERE FIRST GENERATION
--
APPRECIATE THIS CONVERSATION SO
MUCH AND NOW THE OPPORTUNITY
PARTICIPATE AND IT SEEMS THAT
THERE IS A DAUNTING TASK FACING
HIGHER EDUCATION ACROSS THE
VARIOUS SECTORS --
IN AS CHAIR BERMAN SAID WE HAVE
TO RESPOND TO THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE DONE FOR SIXTY YEARS
KEEPING THE STATE'S PROMISED TO
OUR STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
I'M COURSE WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY I DO WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT NOW ONE OF
THE BEAUTIES OF THE CAL GRANT
AND OTHER PROGRAMS IS THAT ALLOW
STUDENTS EVEN THOSE FROM A
NONTRADITIONAL BACKGROUNDS AS
THE CHAIR SAID. TO CHOOSE THE
SCHOOL THAT BEST FITS THEIR
UNIQUE NEEDS --
NOW WE HAVEN'T SPECIFICALLY
TALKED ABOUT IT TODAY BUT ONE OF
THOSE STUDENT POPULATIONS OF
COURSES ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO AS WE ALL KNOW.
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
STUDENT AID SO WE HAVE TO BE
CREATIVE WHEN IT COMES TO
ACKERMAN THOSE GAPS WE WERE UP
PLEASE THIS YEAR TO SUPPORT --
SOME OF THEM THE MOANS --
AB TENTH OR I CAL GRANT BE
SERVICE AND SENATE GRANT FOR
THOSE STUDENTS AND THEN ANOTHER
AYE UNIQUE STUDENT POPULATION OF
COURSE IS OUR VETERANS AYE MR
MEDINA HAD A BILL THIS YEAR
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO THAT
WOULD CREATE A OR I SHOULD SAY
PERPETUATE.
THE GI BILL WARD FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA MILLION APARTMENT
VETERAN SO ANYWAY JUST COUPLE
THINGS THAT WE ARE A EXCITED TO
SEE YOU PUT FORTH THIS YEAR.
AND ALL THAT SAID ONCE HE THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE CONVERSATION
OPPORTUNITY PARTICIPATE AND I
PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW WE CAN
YOU.
THANK YOU JOHN THAN.
NEXT WE HAVE DAISY MAXIMIAN
FOLLOWED BY MILES WALK INS.
HELLO I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
CHAIR BERMAN AND AND I ACTUALLY
LIKE TO FORFEIT MY TIME TEMAS
HAWKINS DEAL.
AFTER MILES WILL BE DAVID BALA
HAWKINS.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MYLES WATKINS PRESIDENT CEO OF
ASSOCIATES TO THE CORPORATE AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EAST BAY IN BEAUTIFUL HAYWARD
CALIFORNIA.
I HEARD A LOT OF THINGS SAID
TODAY.
A LOT OF TWENTY FIVE CENT WORDS
A LOT OF THIRTY CENT WORDS.
BUT THE ONLY METRIC THAT MATTERS
IN THIS IS OUR REALITY.
STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS AND HUNGRY
ON A DAILY BASIS BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT TOLD WHAT COLLEGE ACTUALLY
BECAUSE IT WERE ONLY WORRIED
ABOUT TUITION.
NOTHING NOTHING'S GONNA GET DONE
EVEN TODAY ME AND MY VICE
PRESIDENT WERE SPEAKING AT MY
OLD HIGH SCHOOL I GREW UP TEN
MINUTES AWAY FROM HERE IN THE
THOMAS.
I WAS SPEAKING TO THEM AND THEY
WERE ASKING DO YOU GET
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR TUITION AND I
SAID. OH YEAH I DO
.
BUT THAT'S WE LESS THAN WHAT IT
ACTUALLY COSTS. 40% OF CSU
STUDENTS ARE FOOD INSECURE 10%
ARE HOMELESS AND AT OUR CAMPUS
55% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION.
BIGGER ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE GROUPS ACTUALLY GOING
THROUGH THIS.
AND AS A STUDENT LEADER AS
PRESIDENT CEO OF MY STUDENT BODY
SHIRLEY WAS HERE I KNOW HER A A
SIGH PRESIDENT FROM SANDY
OPENINGS CHRISTOPHER THOMAS.
THIS I IF I PRESIDENT FOR SAN
WAS PAYING HIS NAME IS JUAN
CARLOS HERNANDEZ.
SINCE ENORMOUS STATE THAT'S
CARLY CHATTERLEY AND IN SAN JOSE
STATE THAT'S OUR YARD NOW MANZO
WE ARE ALL HERE. TO HELP
STUDENTS.
BE THE FOCUS OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PRESIDENT WALK INS.
NEXT UP WE HAVE DAVID BALA
HAWKINS FOLLOWED BY MARIO.
DOUG OF ERA CORVAIR [inaudible]
CORDERO.
THAT MISTER BERMAN THANK YOU OUT
FIRST EIGHT THAT DIED LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE YOUR STAFF AS WELL
THEY'VE --
THEY'VE JUST BEEN OUTSTANDING
VERY RESPONSIBLE AND WE'VE
THINGS --
YOU KNOW HEARING THE STUDENTS
SPEAK I'M I'M REALIZING HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR A LONG LONG
TIME -- I
USED TO BE THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHEN WE
HAD FORMULA DRIVEN BUDGETS.
AND SO BASED ON STUDENT
POPULATION YOU HEARD SO MANY
FACULTY SO MANY STAFF SO MANY
MANAGERS UNDER THE PETE WILSON
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE OF THE
BUDGET WE THROUGH WHAT WAS
CALLED THE ORANGE BOOK AWAY.
AND NOW WE GIVE A PART OF MONEY
TO THE CSU AND TRUSTED THAT
THEY'RE GONNA SPEND IT
ACCORDINGLY.
AND WHAT THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
IT IS IT IS THAT IT'S NOT
WORKING.
THE CURRENT FUNDING MODEL FOR
THE CSU.
IS NOT WORKING WE EVEN TOOK THEM
OUT FROM BEING UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
OVERSIGHT.
AND YOU FOLKS DON'T KNOW HOW
THEY SPEND MONEY YOUR BUDGET
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW HOW THIS
YEAR SHE'S BEEN SPENDING.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME OTHER
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES SUB BASED ON
IT TO THOUGHT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AUDIT THAT DOCTOR
WEBER ACTUALLY AUTHORED --
THAT THE CSU EMPLOYEES UNION WHO
I WORK FOR NOW AROUND ACTUALLY
SPONSORED.
GROWTH IN MANAGEMENT OVER A TEN
YEAR PERIOD WAS DOUBLE THE RATE.
OF THE GROWTH IN CSU SUPPORT
STAFF.
COMPENSATION FOR MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS CRUDE A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS HAVE THE CSU
BUDGET.
THE AUDITOR STATE AUDITOR
CONCLUDED THAT SEE IF YOU CAN'T
BUSINESS CANNOT ADEQUATELY
JUSTIFY THE SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN MANAGEMENT PERSONNEL AND
THEIR COMPENSATION.
THE AUDITOR SAID THAT HE IF YOU
CAMPUS IS QUOTE.
DO NOT ADEQUATELY OVERSEE THEIR
BUDGETS.
WHICH REDUCE ASSURANCES THAT
STATE FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT
EFFICIENTLY.
AND APPROPRIATELY.
WE'VE GOT EXECUTIVES AND EARNING
A CLOSE TO A HALF HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR NOW.
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
THEY DON'T GIVE JUST SALARIES.
THEY GET A HOUSING A LAMB WITH
HIS THE RANGE FROM FORTY FIVE TO
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
CARL OUNCES FROM ELEVEN TO
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
AND MANY OF THEM GET FOUNDATION
MONEY OF UP TO THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
SEE IF YOU ALSO HAVE ACCOUNTS
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE TREASURY.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THESE THE CAN'T EVEN HAVE THE
BANK OF THE CSU WHICH AT WHICH I
WAS VERY IMPRESSED.
THOSE THOSE OUTSIDE OF COUNT IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WERE ONE
POINT [inaudible]
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
HIS NOW GROWN TO THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS MAJORITY
OF THAT MONEY IS STUDENT
TUITION.
THERE'S EASILY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OF THIS YEAR IF YOU CAN
SPEND ON ANYTHING RIGHT NOW.
AND YET THEY'RE WALKING AROUND
THE BUILDING TO A TALK MIGHT
HELP.
POOR THAT THEY WERE THIS YEAR.
AND WHEN YOU WORK HARD MISTER
BERMAN TO GET MONEY FOR THE CSU
WHAT DID THEY DO THEY GAVE
SALARY INCREASES TO THEIR
EXECUTIVES DOWN AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE [inaudible]
SO. FOR SUGGESTIONS ON HOW WE
COULD IMPROVE THIS QUICKLY
PLEASE YOU BET. ONE IS BUT THE
CSU BACK UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
THE THEY AREN'T SPENDING MONEY
ON THE EXPERTS THAT FINANCE
ALREADY HAS.
SECONDLY LOOK AT POSSIBLY
INSTITUTING SOME MORE FUNDING
FORMULAS.
AND NOT JUST GIVE THEM A PART OF
MONEY INTEREST IS GOING TO BE
SPENT ACCORDINGLY. THREE LIMITS
THE AMOUNT OF MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS AND HOW MUCH CAN BE
SPENT ON ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CSU BUDGET.
AND FINALLY DISALLOW THIS YEAR
IF YOU FROM HAVING ACCOUNTS
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE TREASURY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE MARC ARE MARIO
GUERRERO FALL BY CYNTHIA
CASTILLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BERMAN
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SWANTE TO THINK HOW MY COLLEAGUE
THAT WENT BEFORE ME DAVID UP FOR
HIS COMMENTS --
ALSO WANTED TO THINK YOU FOR THE
SERIES OF HEARINGS --
CFA AS YOU MAY KNOW REPRESENTS
THE TWENTY NINE THOUSAND OR SO
PROFESSOR'S LECTURES LIBRARIANS
AND CANCERS COACHES WHO TEACH IN
THE CSU.
I AM I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE.
YOU DID A GREAT --
SERVICE TO OUR STUDENTS BY YOUR
FUNDING THIS YEAR THAT ALLOWED
IT ALLOWED OVER THREE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
TO ATTEND THE CSU THIS COMING
YEAR AND FOR THAT I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU THAT.
IS ALL ABOUT THE STUDENTS --
HOWEVER WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION FINANCE WITHOUT
REALLY TALKING ABOUT THE THIRTY
ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS THE
QUALIFIED FOR A SEAT FOR THE CSU
BUT WERE NOT ADMITTED TO
DEFINING THIS PAST YEAR --
WE BELIEVE THAT ANY FINANCING
PLAN NEEDS TO TAKE THIS INTO
ACCOUNT AND ALSO REFLECT THE
FULL FUNDING NEEDS OF THE STATE
INCLUDING --
THE STUDENTS LIVING EXPENSES UP
FINANCING SHOULD ALSO CONSIDER
THE CS USE OUR ABILITY TO OFFER
APPROPRIATE LEVEL.
STUDENT SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE WE
KNOW THAT THE CSU HAS A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS.
TO SERVE THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
STUDENTS ARE DE ARE DEALING AS
YOU'VE HEARD ARE DIRECTLY FROM
THEM WITH FOOD AND SECURITY.
AND OR HOMELESSNESS ALL OF THESE
THINGS HAVE AT LEAST.
ONE THING IN COMMON IT'S FUNDING
WE NEED TO FUND THE SYSTEM
APPROPRIATELY TO INCREASE ACCESS
AND QUALITY EDGE OF EDUCATION.
FINALLY STUDENTS ARE DROWNING IN
DEBT ONE I THINK THAT YOU SEIZE
FOR GIVING A ARE GIVING THEIR
STUDENTS A REDUCTION IN TUITION
AND FEES.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT
THEY'VE DONE THAT IN OVER TWENTY
YEARS WE'RE WAITING FOR THE CSU
TO SEE WHAT THEY DO --
WHAT WE REALLY NEED AT THE END
OF THE DAY IS UP THE POLITICAL
WILL TO CREATE A DEDICATED
FUNDING SOURCE TO FULLY AND
ADEQUATELY FUND THE CSU --
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN OUR STATE
AND IN OUR FUTURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MARIO NEXT
ABOVE CYNTHIA CASTILLO FOLLOWED
BY.
NICOLE MOON DOES MARIO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND AL AND
SYNDICATES DION BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE.
WEEPER REPRESENT THAT
COMMUNICATIVE FACULTY ACROSS THE
STATE IS PROFESSIONAL MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION.
SO I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY COME AGO
THE COMMENTS --
BY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADVOCATES THE STUDENTS I'M
VALERIE AL HUNTER LAVALLEE I'D
DON'T THINK I COULD HAVE SAID IT
ANY BETTER SO I WON'T AND DOT
SPECIFIC TO THE SECOND PANEL.
MY COMMENTS WILL BE FOCUSED ON
THE FIRST.
CONVENING THIS MEETING BUT FACT
FIRMLY BELIEVES THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM SHOULD
BE OPEN TO ALL REGARDLESS OF
STUDENTS BACKGROUND RACE OR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
WE REMAIN VERY SKEPTICAL THAT
THE PERFORMANCE SPACE FUNDING
FORMULA LINES WITH THE MASTER
PLAN.
SO WE AGREE WITH MARK MARTIN'S
PREPARED ANALYSIS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB TO WHERE HE
SAID.
THAT IT IS UNCLEAR HOW PUNISHING
COLLEGES WITH POOR PERFORMANCE
BY REDUCING FUNDING WILL LEAD TO
BETTER PERFORMANCE WHAT WE KNOW
WITH THIS FUNDING FORMULAS THAT
IF IT.
ATTRIBUTES A POINT SYSTEM THAT
WE THINK VALUES FULL TIME
STUDENTS OR PART TIME INVALUABLE
DEGREES FOR TRANSFER OVER CARE
AND CT  COURSE SAYS.
AND AND SO SO ON AND SO FORTH.
SO WE ENCOURAGE A CLOSER
EXAMINATION AS TO HOW TO IMPROVE
THE FUNDING FORMULA.
THE POINT SYSTEM THAT IT HAS.
AND THAT WOULD ALIGN WITH THE
MASTER PLAN IN DOES NOT FOR
CLOSE OPPORTUNITY ON AND ACCESS
TO STUDENTS WHO CANNOT ATTEND
FULL TIME THANK YOU.%
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CYNTHIA AND
LAST WE'RE NICOLE MORE KNOWS
MARIO.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOON TERM BERMAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE SERIES
OF HEARINGS THAT YOU'VE HELD I
ALSO WANNA ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MANY PEOPLE ABOUT THE GOOD WORK
OF BOTH ALLEN --
BETWEEN ANALYSTS OF THE SCHMIDT
THEY'VE BEEN JUST TREMENDOUS TO
WORK WITH.
AND PRUNE WE WANNA SAME CRITICAL
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING A
TODAY'S CURRENT CONVERSATION ON
THE STATUS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
FINANCE AND CAL I AM BY THE WAY
MANY OF THE COMMUNIST PARTY ON
I'M.
WITH THIS ISSUE CANCERS OFFICE
AND SO WE HAVE TO SAY.
FIRST OFF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT YOU
GAVE TO THE CSU THIS YEAR.
THE WORK OF YOU THAT OTHER
MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR.
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS GOING
A LONG WAY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
HER GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE EFFORT AND OUR OTHER
SHARED PRIORITIES.
WE PROUDLY SERVE MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND EACH YEAR.
THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS MEET
THEM SEE ISSUE MINIMUM
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND IN
FACT.
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT BY EDUCATION NEARLY
47% OF CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETED A DIGI
AND COLLEGE ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS.
SO AS YOU MOVE FOR TODAY.
REPORT THAT COMES OUT WE DO HOPE
THAT THE CONVERSATION THAT WAS
STARTED ABLE CONTINUE.
WE NEED A LONG TERM FUNDING
STRATEGY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S AN ESSENTIAL
CONVERSATIONS SO THAT OUR
CAMPUSES COMPLAIN.
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
SEAT FOR EVERY QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AND THAT WE
CAN MEET THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
NEEDS.
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE
LOOK FOR ENGAGING IN THIS
CONVERSATION OPPOSE FORD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AND THAT WILL CONCLUDE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING I JUST WANT
THINK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN TODAY'S HEARING AS WELL AS
THE FIVE HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD
--
SINCE SINCE THE BODY YEAR AGO --
MY COLLEAGUES ALL THE PANELISTS
THAT WE'VE HAD ALL THE FOLKS IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED AB ONE WATCHING
ONLINE ALL THE MEETINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD OUTSIDE OF HEARINGS --
IT'S BEEN THE I JUST AND AN
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE --
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE --
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD AT OUR
HEARINGS WE'VE HAD.
ADMINISTRATORS WE'VE HAD FACULTY
WE'VE --
WE'VE HAD FOLKS ON FINANCIAL AID
ISSUES AND AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE'VE HAD STUDENTS --
AND EIGHTY AS A LOT OF FOLKS.
SAID TODAY REALLY IS ALL ABOUT
THE STUDENTS AND WAS AT A
CONFERENCE LATE LAST YEAR THE
FIRST TIME I HEARD --
THAT -- YOU
KNOW YOU'D DIE AID FOR TUITION
FACILITATES COLLEGE ACCESS BUT
AID FOR THE NON TUITION COSTS
FACILITATES CALLED SUCCESS --
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
ALL OF US TO KEEP THAT IN MIND I
THINK SET OUT TO T. GUESS WHO I
THINK FOR SAID THAT --
AND YEAH WE WE WE WE DEFINITELY
--
YEAH THAT THAT HAS TO BE FIRST
AND FOREMOST IN OUR MINDS IS IS
THAT.
THE COST OF BEING ABLE TO ATTEND
COLLEGE IS GONE UP SO
DRAMATICALLY BECAUSE THE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
HAS GONE NOW GONE UP SO
DRAMATICALLY I WOULD NEED TO
FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THOSE --
FACTORS THAT ARE IMPACTING OUR
STUDENTS AS I TRY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AS THEY GO THROUGH --
COLLEGE IN AND GET GOOD JOBS --
SO REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
MORE CONVERSATIONS --
PLEASE STAY TUNED FOR OUR
UPCOMING REPORT.
THE WORK OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO CHECK THE
SUBCOMMITTEES WEB PAGE --
WHICH IS ON AT MY WEBSITE THAT
WE ARE JOB DOWN MENU UNDER
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN OR DON'T
HESITATE TO REACH OUT TO ALLEN
OR ELISABETH.
IN MY OFFICE THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH -- AND
THE HEARING IS ADJOURNED